tiens mes chers collègues nous allons
commencer
bonjour à tous Nous sommes
nous sommes particulièrement nombreux
dans une salle qui est malheureusement
petite donc je vais vous demander plus
encore que les autres fois de vous
discipliner s'il vous plaît pour éviter
que les conversations individuelles ne
fassent un écho et que surtout nous
puissions bien entendre nos invités que
je tiens à saluer et que je vais tout de
suite vous présenter monsieur Denis
raponne membres du collège de l'Autorité
de régulation de la communication
audiovisée du numérique de l'arcom
Madame Lisa bellulo qui est président de
la Fédération Française des Télécoms
monsieur Maxime Sada président de
l'Association pour la protection des
programmes sportifs et évidemment
président du directoire du groupe Canal+
madame Caroline guenetto qui est
secrétaire général adjointe de being
Media Group et Monsieur Mathieu Ficot
qui est directeur général adjoint de la
Ligue de football professionnel nous
avons souhaité organiser cette table
ronde pour faire le point un an après
l'adop de la loi du 25 octobre 2021
relative à la régulation à la protection
de l'accès aux œuvres culturelles à
l'ère numérique sur l'application de son
article 3 relatif à la lutte contre le
piratage des retransmissions sportives
notre commission c'est particulièrement
impliquée sur ce sujet à l'initiative de
Catherine Morin de Sailly nous avions
organisé en janvier 2019 la première
table ronde sur ce thème réunissant des
experts européens venant notamment de
grandes Bretagne et du Portugal pour
présenter une procédure innovante fondée
sur une ordonnance dynamique permettant
aux ayants droits d'engager eux-mêmes
des actions auprès des fournisseurs
d'accès Internet pour couper l'accès au
site pirate il aura fallu près de trois
années pour adopter un autre tour une
procédure similaire grâce à
l'implication de toutes les parties
représentées aujourd'hui autour de cette
table pourquoi était important le
piratage des retransmissions sportives
comme celui des film des séries est
devenu une industrie clandestine à
grande échelle qui affaiblit les
détenteurs des droits et les médias au
profit des structures qui évoluent en
dehors de tout cadre légal fiscal et
social on organisant aujourd'hui cette
table ronde nous souhaitons mesurer le
chemin parcouru depuis un an connaître
les premiers résultats mais aussi
comprendre le rôle de chacun des acteurs
comment s'organise concrètement le
dispositif sur le plan juridique et
technique qui permet de couper l'accès
au site pirate est-ce qu'une coopération
harmonieuse a pu s'établir entre des
acteurs aux intérêts différents après un
an de recul peut-on considérer que ce
dispositif est suffisant et opérationnel
voilà quelques-unes des questions que
nous souhaitons vous poser
je donnerai pour commencer la parole à
Denis Rapon qui interviendra au nom de
l'arcom la recom a produit une enquête
récente sur lequel bien sûr vous allez
revenir je crois que vous devrez partir
à 11h si nous n'avons pas terminé bien
sûr vous les chaperez
nous poursuivrons avec Madame Lisa
bellulo qui pourra nous préciser comment
se passe concrètement l'intervention des
FAI pour couper l'accès au site pirate
j'insiste sur le fait que nous avons
besoin d'une présentation pédagogique
parce que je crois pouvoir dire que
aucun d'entre nous ne sommes vraiment
des spécialistes et experts en
informatique donc
la pédagogie sera notre égard importante
je voudrais suite la parole aux trois
autres intervenants représentant les
ayants droits notamment à Maxime Saada
et Caroline guenotto qui pourront nous
expliquer qu'elle a été l'impact
dispositif mis en place
sur l'abonnement des chaînes payantes
est-ce que vous confirmez la baisse de
76% de l'audience pirate au cours des
six derniers mois pour les matchs de la
Champions League mais nous savons
également que les pirates s'adaptent à
l'évolution de leur environnement
comment le piratage évolue et comment la
lutte contre le piratage doit-elle même
évoluer nous sommes également heureux de
pouvoir entendre Matthieu Ficot
représentant de la Ligue de football
professionnel qui pourra nous indiquer
quel est l'effet de la lutte contre le
piratage sur la valorisation des droits
du football professionnel est-ce que
vous avez pu évaluer cet effet sur le
prix du prochain appel d'offres des
droits de la Ligue 1 que vous lancerez
en 2023 par exemple puis ce sera bien
sûr autour de des sénateurs d'intervenir
s'il le souhaite et nous commencerons
bien sûr par le rapporteur pour
l'audiovisuel Jean Raymond Hugonnet je
vous rappelle enfin que cette audition
est captée et diffusée en direct sur le
site internet du Sénat Monsieur Raphaël
je vais laisser la parole pour quelques
minutes
s'introduire ce débat si beaucoup
monsieur le président
merci
peut-être rapprocher le micro
voilà est-ce que ça va mieux
oui donc je disais que cette table ronde
se situe vraiment dans la continuité des
travaux de cette commission j'ai
souvenir ayant été dans des fonctions
antérieures présidents de la dopie
allez-y je sais pas si voilà c'est le
micro marche bien donc participons
effectivement à une précédente table
ronde mais d'autres travaux et d'autres
échanges qui avaient été organisés sous
l'égide de la Commission et je dois dire
que le dispositif actuel dont je vais
effectivement dire un mot est un
dispositif qui doit beaucoup à
l'ensemble à l'ensemble de ces travaux
et il a permis vraiment d'accompagner
l'émergence d'un consensus entre les
acteurs de ce dispositif un mot pour
être très rapide sur et un chiffre sur
le pourquoi c'est à dire d'où on vient
premier semestre 2021 les pratiques de
piratage et contenu culturels sont best
tendentiel les pratiques de piratage des
contenus sportifs sont en hausse
tendancielle avec plus de 3 millions
d'utilisateurs qui chaque mois
effectivement se connecte pour pouvoir
avoir la possibilité de voir des matchs
non pas d'une manière licite à travers
des abonnements
canal à Bing mais à travers
effectivement toute une galaxie de site
pirate qui leur offre gratuitement la
plupart du temps effectivement l'accès
l'accès au match
le défi que au fond on avait à surmonter
c'était à la fois et c'était assez
difficile en fait et certains d'entre
vous sans doute s'en souviennent lors
des débats de trouver un point
d'équilibre entre d'une part
effectivement la nécessité de pouvoir
instaurer un blocage qui soit efficace
donc rapide puisque voilà le spécificité
des manifestations compétitions
sportives et que la valeur même de la
manifestation de compétition elle
s'éteint voilà en deux heures pour un
match de foot voilà en tout cas dans le
temps même de la compétition et bien sûr
de devoir respecter la liberté de
communication et le rôle du juge qui
voilà est le garant des libertés
publiques et qui doit intervenir donc
d'une manière j'allais dire fondatrice
dans le dans le dispositif et ce qui est
nouveau ce qui est effectivement n'avait
jamais
à ce stade était instauré c'est de
pouvoir concevoir le rôle d'une autorité
administrative en l'occurrence l'arcome
depuis le 1er janvier pour mettre en
oeuvre en réalité d'une manière
dynamique c'est-à-dire dans le temps
dans la durée dans une forme
d'actualisation la décision la décision
du juge alors comment ça se passe ça se
passe voilà là aussi essayer d'être le
plus concret possible parce que moi non
plus j'ai jamais piraté donc je parle de
ce que je ne connais pas en réalité
Personne
voilà on part du principe effectivement
qu'on est tous parfaitement profane en
la matière la première étape c'est
effectivement l'étape de la saisine du
juge alors ceux qui peuvent le saisir ce
sont soit les fédérations ou les ligues
ou encore les chaînes de télévision qui
ont acquis des droits exclusifs de
diffusion souvent à prix d'or et donc
qui doivent saisir le juge en pouvant
mettre en avant la preuve à travers des
constat d'huissiers en réalité et des
captations d'écran que ces sites donc
qu'ils doivent viser bien sûr dans le
dans la dans la saisine du juge porte
des atteintes graves et répétées c'est
vraiment le l'exigence de la loi donc à
leurs droits et il faut que ces
atteintes graves et répétés étaient
occasionné par le contenu d'un site en
ligne dont l'un des objectifs est
principalement la diffusion sous
autorisation de ces compétitions
le juge statut selon une procédure
d'urgence qui est la procédure dite
d'accélérer au fond ou une procédure de
référé et il peut alors prescrire et
c'est très important toute mesure toute
mesure susceptible de faire cesser ses
atteintes envers en réalité toute
personne toute morale qui est en état de
pouvoir le faire
à ce stade et concrètement le juge n'est
saisi que au fin de notifié au
fournisseur d'accès Internet le blocage
de site mais en réalité le dispositif
législatif est beaucoup plus large et
permettrait d'embrasser d'autres
d'autres acteurs j'en dirai un mot sur
j'allais dire les limites actuelles du
dispositif et les voix éventuelles
d'évolution d'évolution possible donc
l'intervention du juge est suivie par
celle de l'arcom c'est la c'est la
deuxième étape
dès lors que la décision judiciaire est
devenue définitive mais que les ayants
droits sportifs
constatent que en réalité la mesure de
blocage est contournée par l'apparition
de sites qu'on appelle les sites miroirs
en réalité qui permettent l'accès
effectivement à la même compétition
les ayants droits peuvent effectivement
saisir saisir l'air comme sur la base en
réalité à nouveau de constatation
en transmettant les données
d'identification des sites évidemment
dont ils ont constaté qu'ils étaient
illicites puisqu'il permettait en
réalité là aussi de pouvoir capter les
matchs qui pourtant faisaient étaient
dans le champ de l'ordonnance de
l'ordonnance judiciaire et nous à
l'arcome à travers la présence d'agents
habilités de l'arcome assermenté donc on
a pour mission d'instruire ces saisines
et de dresser quand on constate
effectivement quasiment que les sites
qui ont été mis en avant par la saisine
des ayants droits sont bien des sites
qui soient diffusent directement soit on
l'objectif c'est à dire dans leur
propositions donc mettre en avant la
diffusion prochaine donc des mêmes
compétitions alors nous sommes
effectivement en capacité de pouvoir
notifier au fournisseurs d'accès
Internet le blocage le blocage de de ces
sites de ces sites miroirs le les seuls
qui peuvent agir en la matière c'est à
dire qu'ils peuvent donner en réalité le
top départ
aux fournisseur d'accès internet ce
n'est pas le collège donc c'est aussi un
élément qui est un peu dire exceptionnel
c'est soit le président du collège soit
le ou les membres qu'il désignera il a
demandé aux deux magistrats Laurence
pecorivolier qui est donc considéré
accords de cassation et votre serviteur
donc est conseillé de pouvoir
effectivement suivre plus
particulièrement cette cette procédure
et de pouvoir valider les notifications
de blocage aux fournisseurs d'accès
Internet concrètement donc on communique
à ceci une liste de noms de domaine qui
sont les noms de domaine correspondants
et donc à ces services illicites alors
comment le dispositif s'est déployé
depuis donc le 1er janvier on a 9 mois
de neuf mois de recul 10 décisions de
justice donc c'est vraiment la clé de
contact du dispositif obtenu par des
diffuseurs canal et Bing une ligue la
Ligue de football professionnel qui
représentée par Matthieu Chicot la
Fédération française de tennis et les
compétitions principalement des
compétitions de football donc
l'Afrique la Coupe d'Afrique des nations
la Ligue 1 et 2 la première ligue le Top
14 ça on passe au rugby et puis des
sports mécaniques et le tennis
le tribunal donc quel tribunal de Paris
compétent pour pour ce type de litige
c'est armé lui-même donc avec
effectivement une magistrate dédiée qui
donc connaît la matière et donc étant
capacité de pouvoir réagir très
rapidement donc
rendent des décisions dans des délais
exceptionnels en cours
j'ai été dans un passé très ancien
magistrat je dois dire que j'ai été
effectivement extrêmement admiratif de
la manière dont les choses se sont
passées au niveau judiciaire mais ça a
été effectivement une une préoccupation
du président du tribunal judiciaire de
faire que cette procédure fonctionne dès
sa mise en place vraiment dans des
délais exceptionnels
à ce moment là donc le blocage qui a été
ordonné à travers ses 10 décisions
embrasse 350 services illicites
et dans le même temps c'est à dire dans
celui comme je l'ai dit qui suit
immédiatement en fait la décision
judiciaire parce que les sites miroirs
sont des sites miroirs très réactifs qui
apparaissent pratiquement dans les
heures qui suivent les jours qui suivent
donc dans l'arcome a été saisi par les
mêmes ayants droits d'ailleurs que j'ai
évoqué de 46 îles et à notifié donc
le blocage de plus de 480 noms de
domaine au fournisseurs d'accès Internet
alors l'instruction nous-mêmes
évidemment on s'est mis en état comme
l'institution judiciaire parisienne
l'avait fait de pouvoir répondre en
général dans un délai qui est de
quelques jours et ensuite je dois le
dire les mesures de blocage sont
appliquées par les fournisseurs d'accès
dans des délais qui eux-mêmes sont des
délais de quelques heures lorsque
l'arcome leur transfert effectivement
les données de ces noms de domaine des
sites des sites illicites donc ce que
vraiment je dois saluer ici à travers
ces neuf mois c'est la qualité d'un
travail d'équipe c'est à dire d'un bout
à l'autre de la chaîne le juge les
ayants droits bien sûr les fournisseurs
d'accès internet je parle l'an dernier
de l'arcome on vraiment jouer chacun un
rôle majeur dans l'efficacité et les
résultats que que je viens de que je
viens d'évoquer en termes de blocage et
je dois le dire de la part des
fournisseurs d'accès Internet à ce stade
sans j'allais dire mettre en avant les
coûts représentés par la mise en œuvre
de ces de ces blocages voilà alors ce
bilan donc il a abouti ce voilà parce
qu'au-delà des blocages on s'est
intéressé à savoir comment l'audience
qui se dirigeait vers les sites
illicites à réagi
alors il se trouve que donc on a observé
que entre janvier 2021 c'est-à-dire
premier semestre 2021 et premier
semestre 2022 de moitié l'audience ici
avec
on est passé donc premier semestre de
l'année dernière à 3 millions 2 de
d'internautes qui en live streaming
avait accès à ces sites illicites par
mois à un million 7 donc des mêmes
internautes qui aujourd'hui
effectivement accède à ces sites
illicites près de la moitié de ce qui
les contenus d'appeler les lives
streamers c'est à dire ces internautes
quand ils sont confrontés au blocage des
sites se détournent de ceci
48%, c'est quand même la moitié
37%, 16 donc leur pratique et 15% vont
vers l'offre légale donc et souscrivent
un abonnement à une des chaînes qui
propose les compétitions auxquelles ils
veulent ils veulent accéder
pour autant parce qu'il faut
effectivement s'intéresser aussi au vert
à moitié vide en quelque sorte il reste
donc 46% d'internautes qui poursuivent
leur pratique ici
en utilisant pour certains donc des
moyens de contournement et donc c'est un
peu j'allais dire vers ces pistes là que
je souhaiterais conclure c'est-à-dire
qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire à partir de
ce constat encore une fois très
satisfaisant mais sans doute insuffisant
il faut que à travers une vigilance
accrue on puisse donc je crois atteindre
trois objectifs le premier objectif
c'est de renforcer par le biais d'accord
entre les fournisseurs d'accès Internet
les titulaires des droits sportifs
renforcer la coopération entre eux et
permettent une mise en œuvre des mesures
de blocage qui s'inscrivent dans une
solution de blocage automatisé c'est
très important car je pense
effectivement que la réactivité du
dispositif peut être serrée deuxième
objectif il faut qu'on améliore les
solutions technologiques de blocage et
travailler aujourd'hui on travaille sur
des blocages DNS c'est-à-dire des noms
de domaine travailler sur le blocage de
par l'adresse IP qui est beaucoup plus
très de la diffusion illicite pour
limiter l'effet des pratiques de
contournement troisième objectif il faut
et la loi nous permet c'est ce que je
disais d'emblée impliquer dans la lutte
contre ce piratage sportif l'ensemble
des intermédiaires techniques de cet
écosystème tel que les fournisseurs de
systèmes de noms de domaine les réseaux
privés virtuels les VPN les services
d'hébergement par exemple l'ATM bref
tous ceux qui permettent actuellement à
12% de ces internautes live streamers
qui confronté au blocage on recouvre à
ces moyens techniques de contournement
DNS alternatif ou VPN qui leur
permettent d'échapper en quelque sorte
aux effets du blocage voilà ce que je
souhaitais rapidement vous donner comme
élément merci Monsieur raffens c'est
très clair je vais passer maintenant la
parole à la loulous pour qu'elle nous
dise un peu concrètement comment se
passe l'intervention des FAI et est-ce
que vous aussi vous avez
identifié des pistes d'amélioration
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs donc
la Fédération Française des Télécoms que
je représente ici et heureuse d'apporter
le témoignage de son expérience dans la
mise en oeuvre de la loi du 25 octobre
2021 qui est à ce stade assez unique en
Europe les fournisseurs d'accès Internet
agissent en quelque sorte en tant que
prestataire
occasionnel du service public lorsqu'ils
exercent déjà depuis longtemps la police
des contenus pour des raisons d'intérêt
public majeures notamment en matière de
lutte contre la P2 port de graphie
contre les incitations publiques à
commettre des actes terroristes ou
encore les propos haineux nous agissons
aussi en tant que prestataire
occasionnel pour lutter contre la
protection pour protéger des intérêts
légitimes nous agissons donc en tant
qu'auxiliaire de la lutte contre les
jeux illégaux ou la protection des
droits de propriété intellectuelles avec
la depuis longtemps et donc plus
récemment dans la protection des droits
sportifs avec la loi du 25 octobre 2021
la loi qui doit beaucoup être travaux de
votre commission fait de la France un
des pays d'Europe dont l'arsenal
juridique est le plus complet je vous
renvoie à cet effet elle a très longue
et très détaillée étude de
l'Observatoire de l'audiovisuel du
Conseil de l'Europe de 2021 qui contient
des études pays par pays nous avons bien
conscience des intérêts en jeu en ce qui
concerne la protection des droits
sportifs avec l'économie évidemment de
l'audiovisuel mais aussi l'économie des
filières sportives et donc nous sommes
fiers de participer à la protection de
ses droits et nous avons également le
souci de respecter les équilibres que
les parlementaires ont pris soin de
dessiner entre d'une part la protection
des droits fondamentaux avec notamment
la liberté d'expression et de
consultation des sites internet dont
nous sommes aussi les garants en matière
pratique et d'autre part l'innovation
avec le blocage des sites miroirs
donc le mécanisme se déroule en deux
étapes il y a d'abord une décision du
juge qui est rendue sur saisine des
ayants droits au début de chaque
compétition de chaque saison qui demande
le blocage de sites pirate identifiés et
qui donne ensuite le pouvoir à l'arcome
d'agir contre de nouveaux sites les
sites miroirs et donc pendant toute la
durée de la compétition ou de la saison
les titulaires de droits sportifs
saisissent à ce moment-là directement
l'arcom pour bloquer des nouveaux sites
les sites miroirs d'un des délais plus
bref alors quelle est notre
positionnement depuis l'entrée en
vigueur de la loi nous avons protégé un
certain nombre de retransmission
sportive notamment de la Coupe d'Afrique
des nations des Ligue 1 et de football
le Top 14 de rugby la Ligue des
Champions Roland-Garros des Grands Prix
de Formule 1 ou de moto ou encore la
première ligue anglaise au total nous
avons bloqué plus de 835 noms de domaine
et nous sommes fiers d'avoir mesuré à
avoir contribué dans la mesure qui a été
décrite par Denis à l'utilisation de
site de streaming illégal nous le
faisons grâce à la bonne coopération de
toutes les acteurs de tous les acteurs
et nous avons conscience de l'importance
d'agir dans des lait bref puisque toute
la valeur économique est portée dans la
première transmission du flux nous
appelons sur la base de cette première
expérience à une industrialisation du
dispositif et nous rejoignons
complètement le vœu de l'arcome sur ce
sujet le législateur a pris soin de
proposer une régulation moderne qui
prévoit que l'arcome élabore un modèle
d'accord pour tous les acteurs et nous
appelons à la mise en oeuvre de ce
modèle d'accord de nos vœux c'est pour
cela que de manière constante et depuis
un an nous avons fait preuve d'une bonne
volonté de coopération en novembre 2021
nous avons proposé un cahier des charges
qui permettait la mise en place d'une
brique technique pour récupérer de
manière automatisée les listes de sites
à bloquer auprès de l'arcome en début
d'année 2022 notamment en février en
juin chaque fois je suis venu à l'arcom
donc en compagnie à des ayants nous
avons proposé un dispositif de
coordination des actions des titulaires
de droits les arcoms et l'opérateur afin
de fluidifier le processus au global et
nous proposons des amendements de
manière raisonnable et constructive au
projet d'accord de l'arcome nous
agissons aussi depuis l'entrée en
vigueur de la loi avec diligence en
mobilisant pour l'instant du personnel
habilité y compris lors d'astreinte et
ces personnels habilités doivent parfois
composer avec des demandes multiples de
demandes de blocage pour des raisons
d'intérêt public majeures et de
protection des droits sportifs pour les
seuls blocages de droits sportifs compte
tenu l'exigence de diligence que je
rappelais que nous respectons les
astreintes nécessitent pour l'instant
une personne qui active le blocage de
manière manuelle un ingénieur réseau et
un ingénieur DNS nous avons également
engagé des investissements spécifiques
sans perspective certaines d'être
compensées et nous acquitons aussi des
honoraires d'avocat à ce jour dans une
dizaine d'instances sans être compensés
non plus ce qui est paradoxal parce en
vertu du principe constitutionnel de
juste rémunération dans tous les autres
domaines dans lesquels nous agissons en
tant que prestataire occasionnel du
service public ou auxiliaire de la
protection des droits nous sommes en
principe compensé du fait de la loi ou
du fait d'accord neutroposition est
guidée par quatre principes d'abord à
l'égalité de traitement des titulaires
de droit l'efficience et l'efficacité
opérationnelle pour miniser les coûts
d'investissement quel que soit les
personnes qui les prend en charge et les
coûts opérationnels le respect du
principe de proportionnalité je suis
moi-même ancienne juriste je suis
toujours juriste d'ailleurs dans
l'entreprise dans laquelle je travaille
on est juré sur le reste en général et
donc ce principe de proportionnalité il
est au cœur du droit constitutionnel et
européen et il a pour conséquence que
doivent être minimisés les atteintes à
la liberté de consultation des sites
Internet et notamment les surblocages
et enfin nous demandons évidemment la
compensation des coûts nous demandons
pas d'être rémunéré en dégageant un
bénéfice nous demandons simplement de ne
pas travailler un pur perte alors que
nous travaillons pour le compte d'autres
opérateurs privés en tant qu'opérateur
privé pour que chacun y trouve son
compte ce que nous avons proposé dans le
projet d'accord depuis un an c'est
d'aller au-delà un peu de ce que prévoit
le minimum légal de faire mieux pour
tout le monde ce que nous mettons aussi
à la place des autres parties à l'accord
et de nous saisir tous des opportunités
d'un accord donc nous proposons de
simplifier les procédures en
industrialisant en automatisant le
traitement de demande plutôt que de
faire appel à chaque fois à des
personnels habilités pour cela nous
avons besoin du calendrier de
manifestation sportive qui nous sont
donnés d'ailleurs de mieux en mieux nous
avons besoin de format de fichiers
harmonisés d'une autonomie utilisation
des blocages nous nous engageons même à
pouvoir bloquer les sites avec
l'industrialisation en 45 minutes ce qui
est quand même un délai de réaction
extrêmement efficaces et nous demandons
simplement la compensation des coûts
donc les enjeux sont de 500.000 euros
d'investissement et de développement
initial dont nous proposons de prendre
en charge la moitié donc de partager
entre les ayants droits et les
fournisseurs d'accès Internet et la
compensation des coopérationnels
courants des blocages de sites donc
150000 euros par an donc nous prenons en
charge la moitié et nous attendons des
ayons droits qu'ils prennent en charge
la moitié nous avons évidemment en
justifié la nature de ses coups je vais
vous en faire grâce ici mais on a quand
même deux étalons de comparaison d'abord
l'enjeu économique des droits sportifs
qui est plus d'un milliard par an
d'euros par an donc je crois que le coût
est quand même raisonnable par rapport
aux gains qui peut être dégagé et aussi
le coup qui avait été chiffré par
l'Inspection générale des finances en
toute indépendance pour l'identification
des pirates au profit de la dopie qui
est de 120000 euros par an donc ça
revient la même chose pour les
coopérationnels courants si je mets de
côté les coûts d'investissement
donc ces investissements nous les
faisons en régie donc nous appelons nos
vœux un aboutissement prochain des
travaux afin de permettre aux équipes
des opérateurs d'agir de manière plus
efficace et plus automatisée avec un
cadre standardisé ce sera vraiment
l'intérêt de tous le système de blocage
manuel actuel et précaire egare à la
volumétrie aux attentes légitimes et
importantes des titulaires de droit je
crois que nous avons prouvé notre
efficacité nous pouvons encore faire un
saut qualitatif donc nous souhaitons
nous saisir de cette opportunité de cet
accord qui sera un pas important nous
avons tissé des relations de confiance
je l'espère avec nos nouveaux
interlocuteurs en tout cas nous y
travaillons tous les jours justement en
montrant le succès des mécanismes de
blocage nous espérons que nous serons
deux à vouloir danser le tango comme on
dit souvent à Bruxelles même s'il est
retransmissions de cette danse qui peut
être sportive n'a pas fait à ce jour
l'objet d'une demande de blocage
donc cet accord sera important il faut
il suffira pas à lui seul nous sommes
prêts aussi à étudier à partir du moment
où le cadre est précis le blocage IP
pour l'instant nous y voyons beaucoup de
difficultés techniques parce que autant
une adresse DNS et univoque autant les
adresses IP il peut y en avoir un
milliard par site et elles sont
réattribuées en permanence donc il y a
des risques de surblocage qu'on a vu en
Autriche nous sommes prêts pour autant à
mener toutes les études nécessaires pour
progresser du blocage DNS vers l'étude
des blocages IP mais pour ça ils font un
cadre très clair on est prêt à discuter
le cahier des charges de l'étude avec
les autres parties et nous avons besoin
d'être sécurisé du point de vue de la
responsabilité s'il y avait des
surblocages et puis également d'être
certain que
nous serons compensés de nouveaux coups
qui à ce moment là serait nécessaire
sachant que pour l'instant il n'y a pas
d'outils sur étagère enfin devenir Apple
a rappelé d'ailleurs que ce soit avec le
blocage D sous le blocage JP il existe
des moyens de contournement et l'accord
en lui-même est le travail des FAI et
des ayants droits ne sera pas suffisant
à lui seul pour enrayer les mécanismes
de piratage et les filières de piratage
il faudra aussi travailler sans doute
avec les hébergeurs les plateformes
d'hébergement afin qu'ils mettent en
place des mécaniques de détection de
contenu illicites nous ne pouvons pas le
faire de notre propre initiative parce
que c'est au cœur des principes
concessionnelles c'est au cœur des
principaux européens la directive
e-commerce et du Règlement internet
ouvert mais eux peuvent le faire il
faudrait travailler aussi sans doute
avec les éditeurs de système
d'exploitation afin d'éviter par exemple
Kyos 15 permettre le contournement des
mesures techniques de protection avec
les éditeurs de moteurs de recherche qui
mettent en place de nouvelles méthodes
de chiffrement les éditeurs de VPN et
puis tous ceux qui commercialisent les
boîtiers IPTV illégaux c'est un travail
de longue haleine et de long terme donc
vous l'avez compris le système actuel de
traitement manuel déblocage et précaires
nous souhaitons aller vers
l'industrialisation nous faisons des
efforts depuis un an pour parvenir à un
accord j'espère que tout le monde se
saisira dès cette opportunité et que
chacun fera preuve d'esprit sportif donc
les FAI que je représente ici et puis
les trois représentants des endroits qui
sont ici et puis
au besoin de toute façon nous avons un
arbitre autour de la table je vous
remercie nous allons rester sur merci
Madame nous allons rester sur
l'application de la loi de mandat aux
ayant droit quel est leur vision de un
an après de de du piratage est-ce que
les données que nous allez chiffrer
indiquer monsieur raphone qui sont à
base d'un sondage en fait est-ce que
vous voulez les constater bien aussi en
termes de
d'audience
et est-ce que vous voyez le piratage
évolué je vais peut-être commandé
pardonner la parole à Monsieur Saada
si vous le voulez bien merci bonjour
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs Monsieur le
Conseiller madame la Présidente je
tenais à vous remercier pour
l'initiative de cette table ronde je me
souviens en effet avoir été dans cette
salle parmi les gens sollicités il y a
quelques années elle viendra rappeler le
soutien porté de longue date par le
Sénat à ce sujet la lutte contre le
piratage des contenus audiovisuel et
notamment sportif car nous n'oublions
pas que ce qui nous permet de nous
réunir aujourd'hui et de pouvoir vous
dresser devant vous un premier bilan
objectivement positif de la mise en
oeuvre depuis janvier 22 de l'article 3
de la loi de 2021 c'est bien là juste
après mention des enjeux du piratage
sportif par le Parlement et tout
particulièrement par le Sénat qui a
permis d'aboutir à la définition d'un
dispositif concerté proportionné et à
notre sens adapté
si vous en êtes d'accord j'ai d'abord
m'adresser à vous en tant que président
de lapse avant de faire un point plus
spécifique pour pour Canal+ et avant de
laisser la parole à Caroline Gento
secrétaire général adjointe de bean
Media Group et de Mathieu Ficot DGA à
LFP qui vous présente également leur
propre bilan
pour mémoire nos trois organisations
sont à l'initiative de l'Association
pour la protection des programmes
sportives donc laps créé en 2018 et
réunissant à la fois ayant droit et
diffuseur j'en profite d'ailleurs pour
saluer l'ensemble des autres membres
dont certains sont présents dans la
salle qui sont mobilisés depuis toutes
ces années dans ce combat commun
tout d'abord nous pouvons collectivement
nous satisfaire des premiers mois de la
mise en place du nouveau dispositif issu
de l'article 3 de la loi qui a démontré
une bonne coordination des partis
prenantes et qui permet d'afficher des
premiers résultats concrets comme cela
vient d'être rappelé ce dispositif
introduit d'une manière inédite en droit
français un nouveau moyen de lutter
contre le piratage sportif en complétant
les outils jusqu'à la offert par la loi
nous allons vous expliciter autant que
nos besoins le dispositif de l'article 3
dans sa mécanique les membres de lapse
l'ont mobilisé individuellement mais
notre ambition partagée a permis dès le
mois de janvier nous coordonnées et
d'échanger sur les bonnes pratiques nous
avons appris ensemble à mobiliser au
mieux le nouvel outil d'abord dans la
première étape que constitue l'obtention
d'une décision judiciaire dite
ordonnance cadre sur une compétition
donnée et que les FAI mettent en œuvre
sur la base une première liste de sites
à bloquer comme la rappeler ma voisine
la présidente et juriste
puis dans la seconde étape pour mettre à
jour ces mesures de blocage tout au long
de la compétition en intégrant de
nouveaux sites par le biais d'une
saisine de la recommande via un process
défini avec l'autorité et les premiers
résultats de cette mobilisation
collective sont là selon l'arcom et
comme l'a expliqué de n'irapon la moitié
des lives streamers confrontés au
blocage ce serait détourner des sites et
des sites dont nous le confirmons la
chute tendance de l'audience décide de
Live Streaming illicite et corroborer
par d'autres analyses et données
notamment celle fournit tout récemment
par l'alpin et par Médiamétrie l'étude
Mediamétrie mesure un écart significatif
d'audience des sites étudier entre avril
2021 avec 2,7 millions d'utilisateurs en
avril 21 unique sur le mois d'avril et
373 minutes utilisateurs uniques en
avril
20227 373 000
je précise que ces chiffres reflètent la
méthodologie appliquée par leurs sources
ici Médiamétrie chacun va pouvoir
revenir dans le détail sur ces résultats
individuels mais nous pouvons d'ores et
déjà nous réjouir collectivement des
premiers effets de l'article 3 nous
devons surtout nous satisfaire de la
coordination de l'ensemble des parties
prenantes qui en ressort ce bilan
positif et les résultats d'une d'un
alignement des planètes entre la volonté
des titulaires de droit la compréhension
rapide du juge la diligence des
opérateurs télécoms et l'accompagnement
efficace de l’arcome qui a permis
d'obtenir très rapidement les premiers
résultats sur les blocages un
remerciement tout particulier à l'arcom
évidemment d'abord à devenir Apple mon
expertise et l'engagement nous
accompagne depuis de nombreuses années
ainsi que Madame la conseillère Laurence
Bécaud Rivolier Paulien de la celle qui
est ici et Raphaël berger directeur de
la création Arcom pour leur travail
quotidien à nos côtés dans la mise en
place du nouveau dispositif sport
un remerciement également au FAI pour
leur diligence que je confirme dans la
mise en oeuvre des premières mesures de
blocage les discussions sont
constructives dont les moments depuis
plusieurs mois et elle nous donne bon
espoir d'aboutir rapidement un accord
pour cranter cette collaboration et
aller vers les prochaines étapes nous
tenons là encore à souligner le rôle
précieux que je vous la recommande dans
cette séquence nous devons toutefois
rester prudent malgré la baisse de
l'audience de ces sites illicite le
report des consommateurs vers une offre
légale n'est pour autant pas assurée
comme la rappeler Denis Rapon certains
utilisateurs se sont ventilés dans une
certaine mesure vers un contournement
des mesures de blocage DNS mis en place
par les FAI grâce à l'utilisation de DNS
alternatif ou de VPN ou vers un
visionnage illégal de ces contenus en
direct sur certaines plateformes comme
Twitter Tik Tok ou telegram depuis les
premiers blocages la diffusion en direct
a considérablement augmenté sur ses
plateformes ou les délais fermeture
demeurent insuffisants malgré un début
de collaboration avec elle
surtout dans une plus forte mesure ces
utilisateurs se sont reportés vers la
consommation illégale de l'IPTV comme
l'explicite l'étude de l'arcom et j'y
reviendrai j'aviens tout de suite
d'ailleurs le piratage IPTV est en
réalité un nébule un abus de langage il
s'agit d'une utilisation contrefaisante
d'objets légaux à l'instar de boîtier de
smartphone d'ordinateur ou de télévision
connectée ceux-ci sont détournés de leur
usage légal lorsqu'une application
illégale et téléchargée pour donner
accès à des contenus piratés ce mode de
consommation illicite est
particulièrement destructeur de valeur
en effet à la différence des sites de
live streaming qui piratent les contenus
le piratage
IPTV attaque lui notre modèle même en
vendant des abonnements
et nous avons de quoi nous inquiéter
nous comprenons de l'étude de l'arcom
que 9% des internautes utilisent de
l'IPTV illicite pour regarder les
compétitions sportives ce qui représente
40% des consommateurs ayant des usages
sportifs illégaux
nous avons pour notre part des éléments
qui viennent confirmer les tendances
exprimées dans l'étude de la com quant
au report de l'usage illicite vers
l'IPTV nous identifions au quotidien une
présence accrue de ces offres illégales
d'abonnement IPTV sur les réseaux
sociaux que nous scanons l'organisme
similar web a subi l'évolution de
l'audience de certains services IPTV non
nous savons qu'ils sont très utilisés en
France par exemple le service premium au
TT est ainsi passé de moins de 50 000
utilisateurs mensuels en décembre 2021 à
200 000 utilisateurs en septembre 2022
le service ePlay ou iplay et lui passer
de 45 000 utilisateurs en décembre 2021
à 145 000 utilisateurs en septembre 2022
c'est pourquoi nous ne pouvons nous
arrêter au premier signaux positif de la
mise en place de l'article 3 cette
expérience va nous encourager à aller
plus loin pour structurer massifier la
lutte en s'adaptant à ce phénomène
protéiforme qui est le piratage
chacun aura l'occasion de revenir sur
les axes de sa stratégie individuelle
nous nous partageons déjà les mêmes
constats et objectifs premièrement nous
devons orienter nos actions vers la
lutte contre le préjudice majeur causé
par l'IPTV cette priorisation nous
obligera à mobiliser le second outil
technique de lutte contre le piratage
qui lui est techniquement le plus adapté
à savoir le blocage dit
IP nous savons en effet que pour lutter
contre cette pratique de piratage la
méthode de blocage la plus efficace et
celle du blocage de la source donc de
l'adresse IP c'est d'ailleurs le choix
opéré en Angleterre par la première
ligue au premier championnat de football
du monde avec qui nous échangeons et qui
attribue au blocage IP obtenu par voie
judiciaire une baisse extrêmement
significative de la consommation
illégale IPTV
deuxièmement nous allons devoir prendre
en compte l'ensemble de l'écosystème
complexe du piratage nous devons élargir
nos actions au-delà des opérateurs
télécoms dont j'ai rabbé le la logique
constructive aux autres intermédiaires
techniques pour que chacun participe à
la mesure de l'impact qu'il peut avoir
pour endiguer le piratage l'effort ne
peut être que collectif face à des
pirates organisés comme des structures
mafieuses ou des cartels de la drogue
l'APS et ses membres sont pleinement
engagés à poursuivre leur entente et
fournir leurs meilleurs efforts pour
continuer à ce combat il ne s'agit pas
d'une simple question de protection
industrielle mais aussi de maintien de
l'écosystème du sport et de sauvegarde
de l'ordre public dans la sphère
numérique à ce titre nous sommes heureux
de pouvoir compter sur le soutien du
législateur et de la com
pour Canal+ et pour que les choses
soient claires j'affirme que le piratage
est le premier concurrent de Canal+ en
France et dans le monde la destruction
de valeur est massive pour un acteur de
paye TV a fortiori dans un modèle
généraliste au présent à la fois sur le
sport le cinéma et l'audiovisuel
Canal+ tire son propre bilan positif de
la mobilisation du niveau dispositif
issu de l'article 3 notamment en termes
de recrutement d'abonnés groupe Canal+ a
obtenu 8 ordonnances permettant le
blocage de site de live streaming et
Lego depuis janvier 2022
c'est en fait une est en cours trois
décisions sont désormais inactives
puisque les compétitions sont arrivées à
leur terme il s'agit des saisons passées
du Top 14 de la Ligue des Champions et
de la première ligue 5 décisions sont
actives ou en cours celles sur la moto
GP celle sur la Formule 1 qui sont
actives jusqu'en novembre celles sur les
saisons en cours de la première ligue du
Top 14 et de la Ligue des Champions
au total depuis le début de l'année 2022
Canal+ a obtenu le blocage de 171 sites
par le biais des premières décisions ces
décisions étaient mises à jour pendant
la compétition viennent quarantaine de
saisines d'actualisation que nous
formulons auprès de la com ces nouvelles
saisies n'ont permis au total le blocage
à ce jour de près de 500 noms de domaine
et probablement 600 d'ici à la fin de
l'année outre la baisse significatif de
l'audience décide de live streaming que
nous avons appelé tout à l'heure nous
avons surtout pu identifier les effets
sur nos abonnements
l'analyse interne des recrutements
opérée lors de cinq journées phares de
compétition sportive sur lequel le
groupe a obtenu des ordonnances de
blocage à savoir le Top 14 la Champions
League la Formule 1 la moto GP la
première ligue a permis d'observer une
augmentation de 55 % des recrutement sur
ces journées phares par rapport à 2021
il est bien sûr irréaliste d'attribuer
cette croissance du parc abonné
exclusivement aux facteurs de blocage
des sites mais ce dernier a
nécessairement contribué à l'évolution
positive du nombre de recrutements la
concordance calendaire entre les
blocages opérés à quelques heures des
rencontres voir à quelques minutes des
rencontres comme le Mad PSG Real Madrid
ne peut avoir ne peut qu'avoir eu pardon
un impact positif sur la très forte
hausse de recrutement observée nos
perspectives pour l'un des 2023 sont
évidemment une massification de ce que
nous avons initié en 2022 en prenant en
compte les décisions en cours
d'obtention nous devrions sur l'année
civile 2023 toute compétition confondues
réalisées environ 76 îles comprenant
chacune qu'un site
c'est à dire un nombre total de cils
bloqués au cours de l'année 2023 qui
devrait dépasser les 1000 sites
à noter que cette projection ne prend
pas en compte le sujet de l'IPTV dont
j'ai parlé
Canal+ dont on est fait désormais
accélérer sa stratégie dans le contrôle
IPTV pour ne pas perdre irrémédiablement
la bataille des contenus cette bataille
ne se livre pas entre les plateformes de
SVOD et les acteurs traditionnels comme
on voudrait bien le croire mais plutôt
entre l'ensemble des acteurs légaux et
les pirates qui les pirent ce fléau
pourrait véritablement remettre en
question les modèles de Payet TV en
jouant sur une ambiguïté la difficulté
vient que de nombreux utilisateurs ne
pensent pas être dans l'illégalité car
il paye une forme d'abonnement cela
pourrait s'apparenter très concrètement
à un double maléfique de mycanal
les outils actuels qu'il s'agisse d'une
notice and takedown ou de la loi ou des
blocages DNS ne sont malheureusement pas
assez efficaces pour atteindre
sensiblement le piratage IPTV
l'enjeu n'est pas d'éradiquer le
piratage ne soyons pas dupe la
contrefaçon existe depuis la nuit des
temps mais il s'agit de trouver le point
de sortie viable d'une crise à venir
liée à l'IPTV en perfectionnant un outil
adapté qui puisse le limiter
je rappelle que les acteurs de l'IPTV et
leurs revenus échappent totalement au
pays dans lesquels ils mettent à
disposition leur offre que ce soit
fiscalement ou réglementairement il ne
participant rien au cercle vertueux
liant les droits audiovisuels et
l'économie globale du sport sur un sujet
que le Sonia connaît bien ses acteurs ne
sont ni soumis à des obligations
éditoriales ni à des obligations
d'investissement dans la création
donc j'y reviens la solution et je
conclurai là dessus la plus efficace
contre le phénomène complexe de l'IPTV
et je ne nie pas la complexité semble
aujourd'hui être le second outil
technique accessible à savoir le blocage
via l'adresse IP il permet de résoudre
notamment la difficulté d'approche aussi
d'acteur illégal en bloquant l'accès à
la source c'est-à-dire au serveur qui
héberge les flux ou les contenus
proposés par les services IPTV
c'est d'ailleurs le choix opéré par
certains voisins européens tels que la
première ligue je l'ai dit qui en tirent
un bilan très positif Canal+ est
pleinement conscient des investissements
que va induire la lutte contre l'IPTV
illégale mais c'est un effort auquel le
groupe consentira pour sauvegarder son
modèle de développement ainsi que la
valeur créée sur le territoire que ce
soit pour le sport ou les autres
contenus c'est un apératif industriel
mais surtout collectif pour préserver
les écosystèmes et politiques publiques
touchés par ces pratiques il est cités
dangereuses
après l'exposé de mes collègues me tient
naturellement à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos questions merci encore de
votre suivi de votre écoute et surtout
pour votre mobilisation sur ce sujet
essentiel merci Monsieur Sada madame
Gento
monsieur le Président bonjour mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs merci de nous
recevoir autour de cette table ronde
c'est l'occasion également pour BeIn
Sport de remercier l'engagement du Sénat
à nos côtés dans la lutte contre le
piratage des contenus sportifs et plus
particulièrement l'engagement résolu
constant de monsieur le sénateur Michel
Savin du côté de BeIn Sport nous
mesurons le chemin incroyable que nous
avons parcouru depuis 2017 et les
premières initiatives parlementaires et
aujourd'hui 5 ans après ses premières
initiatives nous avons rempli une partie
des objectifs que nous nous étions fixés
via l'adoption de cette loi en octobre
dernier le Sénat nous invite aujourd'hui
à dresser un bilan et ce bilan et comme
Monsieur Rapon et Monsieur Saada voulons
dire extrêmement positif toutefois de
nouveau défi nous attend bien évidemment
dans la lutte incessante contre le vol
que constitue le piratage s'agissant du
bilan que BeIn Sport pourrait dresser je
vous rappelle que BeIn Sport ne diffuse
que des contenus sportifs premium nous
avons initié notre première action de
moi après l'adoption de la loi
c'est-à-dire en janvier au fin de
protéger la coupe la Coupe d'Afrique des
nations
nous avons obtenu et c'était très
important une décision très rapide c'est
à dire dans les trois jours
et puis nous avons par ailleurs lancé
deux autres décisions pour la protection
de la Ligue des Champions et pour Will
blonden actuellement nous préparons bien
évidemment notre dossier en vue de
protéger la Coupe du monde dont on a pu
dont on mesure d'ores et déjà le fléau
que pourrait être le piratage sur un
événement de cette importance
on a constaté comme l'a dit Monsieur
Rapon et Monsieur Saada une baisse de
l'audience pirate les audiences
UCL ont été divisées l'audience pirate
des matchs de Champions League a été
divisé par 4
et nous tirons donc trois enseignements
de cette première phase premièrement la
loi fonctionne extrêmement bien
puisqu'elle fonctionne tant pour des
compétitions qui se déroulent sur toute
la durée de la saison c'est-à-dire neuf
mois que sur des durées extrêmement
courtes comme livre le donne ou Roland
Garros dont je vous rappelle la durée et
de 15 jours donc ça c'était ça faisait
partie d'un point d'interrogation et
nous sommes très satisfaits de voir que
justement elle s'applique sur les
événements courts et notamment sur les
événements tels que la Coupe du monde
que dont je vous ai parlé et en
troisième enseignement
c'est l'obtention de ce succès bien
évidemment passe par une mobilisation
forte des moyens tant humain que
financiers donc
juste pour vous rappeler en amont
les ayants droits sont censés rapporter
la preuve que nous subissons des
atteintes graves et répétées
comment dire en matière de de diffusion
de contenu sportifs et donc nous sommes
tenus à apporter des preuves constantes
pour que le juge puisse rendre sa
décision donc ça veut dire que nous
procédons à de nombreux constats nous
passons par des huissiers enfin c'est
une constitution du dossier en vue de
passer devant le juge qui est
extrêmement lourde après vous avez
effectivement en aval de la décision les
saisines que nous faisons auprès de la
com qui nécessitent également que l'on
continue de dresser des constats tous
les jours afin de pouvoir actualiser la
liste des sites que nous avions
identifiés en première instance et qui
permettra à l'arcom de pouvoir procéder
au blocage successifs
donc tout ça pour vous dire que la lutte
contre le piratage du point de vue des
ayants droits est extrêmement
coûteux non seulement moyen dommage
comme on l'a dit subit par par
l'industrie l'écosystème du sport mais
c'est lutte contre le piratage
occasionne de nombreux frais et coûts
qui sont déjà supportés par les
télédiffuseurs et par les ayants droits
pour pouvoir obtenir la protection de
leur contenu ces investissements ce
chiffre en millions en tout cas pour la
société bi immédiat group à l'échelle
des pays sur lesquels nous diffusons des
contenus premium
donc afin de clore cette partie
consacrée au premier bilan je dirais
pour la première fois que dans la longue
histoire de la lutte contre le piratage
les titulaires de droits peuvent dire
nous avons un coup d'avance en cette
année 2021 mais comme on vous l'a dit il
faut s'adapter et nous savons que le
piratage a un caractère protéiforme et
que nous devons adapter les outils juste
pour clarifier et apporter quelques
précisions par rapport aux précédentes
interventions
l'article 3 tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
conçu permet justement cette adaptation
il ne s'adresse pas forcément au blocage
DNS ou
IP il est extrêmement large puisqu'il
vise toute mesure appropriée à lutter
contre la mise à disposition de contenu
illicite donc ça veut dire que
on avait déjà anticipé que il fallait
procéder au blocage IP et que le DNS ne
serait pas
comment dire suffisant pour pouvoir
répondre à cette problématique donc le
DNS c'est une on va dire la plus simple
et le l'IP était bien évidemment dans
l'esprit de chacun d'entre nous autour
de cette table pour que le dispositif
soit efficace
bien évidemment il y aura d'autres de
même cet article n'a pas vocation à
s'adresser uniquement aux fournisseurs
d'accès Internet il s'adresse à toute
opérateur à tout partenaire de la chaîne
du piratage pas partenaire mais à toute
opérateur qui peut nous aider à lutter
contre le piratage dans le domaine
technique à savoir on l'a vu on l'a vu
les hébergeurs
les moteurs de recherche les Claude fer
les réseaux sociaux etc
sans revenir donc sur la croissance de
l'IPTV illégal on souhaitait également
faire un focus sur sur le fait que le
piratage on l'a vu un petit peu via
monsieur Saada comment dire derrière le
piratage on a affaire à des gens
extrêmement bien organisés
on peut parler de mafia et il y a des
études très intéressantes qui ont été
publiées récemment notamment celle de la
PA qui est un organisme européen pour la
protection des contenus audiovisuels qui
montrent que dans les 61 71 secondes qui
suivent un clic sur un site pirate un
consommateur est confronté au risque de
perte d'identité de vol d'information et
d'identification et de demande de rançon
les risques de virus sont encore plus
élevés pour les consommateurs qui
accèdent à des contenus piratés via des
applications avant avec 57% de chances
que celle-ci contiennent des logiciels
malveillants intégrés
ainsi le piratage ne s'arrête pas
seulement à la protection des ayants
droits et des diffuseurs mais également
à la protection de tout à chacun et même
des citoyens qui naviguent sur Internet
ainsi pour améliorer on est persuadé que
pour améliorer la protection de ce
dispositif le blocage IP comment on l'a
déjà soulevé sera techniquement beaucoup
plus efficace et c'est la raison pour
laquelle les membres de lapse appelent
de leurs vœux la mise en place par les
FAI de ce blocage rappelons que ce
blocage IP est déjà mis en place dans un
grand nombre de pays européens on l'a vu
depuis cinq ans au Royaume-Uni sans
surblocage aucun bloc sur blocage n'a
été constaté c'est également le cas en
Italie c'est également le cas au
Portugal donc ce ne serait pas une
innovation que le blocage IP soit mis en
place en France
évidemment le blocage l'automatisation
et l'industrialisation de ces systèmes
de la nécessité une collaboration encore
plus étroite avec les services de la com
afin que les délais de réaction
d'intervention souhaitent encore plus
réduits et calées sur la protection du
contenu juste je sais pas si on l'a
mentionné dans le cadre des
interventions précédentes mais le
blocage IP ça consiste juste à bloquer
le signal du site uniquement pendant la
durée du match ou de la durée de la
compétition ce qui fait que vous avez un
écran noir qui est limité à 90 minutes
s'agissant d'un match de football ce qui
fait que on pense que c'est une mesure
qui est proportionnée par rapport au
principe dont on a évoqué tout à l'heure
le principe de proportionnalité et
limite les risques de surblocage puisque
on aura un blocage limité dans le temps
à 90 minutes
pour enchaîner rapidement sur sur la
suite et
ce sur quoi l'APSE se tient toujours
enfin est toujours en alerte et il
travaille et travail ardemment sur les
autres moyens pour lutter contre le
piratage évidemment donc nous avons
l'article 3 il y a la transposition de
la directive sur le droit d'auteur qui
nous permet d'agir efficacement sur les
plateformes de partage comme YouTube et
Facebook mais on l'a cité il y a
d'autres acteurs qui sont susceptibles
de nous aider ce sont bien évidemment
les hébergeurs techniques pour lequel on
ne souhaite pas du tout modifier la
lceen mais on souhaiterait mettre en
place un retrait immédiat ou à tout le
moins dans les 30 minutes c'est à dire
un engagement que les hébergeurs une
fois qu'ils sont notifiés procèdent à la
coupure du contenu illégal et c'est dans
ce sens que le call to action récemment
lancé à Bruxelles par centaines de
titulaires de droits a été
fait visant à palier si vous voulez les
lacunes qu'il y a dans le digital
service actes qui a été comme vous le
savez
voter récemment par la par la Commission
autre obligation sur lequel on pourrait
également s'attacher et concentrer nos
efforts les obligations de traçabilité
la fameuse New York customer New York
business cosmer qui permet d'identifier
les entreprises qui opère sur Internet
ces obligations pourraient être
renforcées en effet le DSA aujourd'hui
n'a prévu cette obligation que pour les
places de marché et là encore c'est une
occasion pour nous manquer de mettre en
place un Internet Plus Sûr pourquoi car
dans les faits les pirates ne peuvent
pas mettre leurs services en ligne sans
un nom de domaine sans être hébergé ou
sans service de publicité ou de paiement
ce sont donc tous les fournisseurs de
ses services qui devraient avoir le
devoir d'empêcher l'accès à leur service
aux entreprises qui refusent de se
conformer aux règles d'identification
et de telles dispositions ne viendraient
en aucune façon endommager notre article
3 pour lequel nous sommes réunis
aujourd'hui
donc une fois encore nous souhaitons
remercier le Sénat pour son engagement
nous souhaitons et nous espérons que
vous resterez à nos côtés pour suivre
les débats et notamment
l'automatisation l'industrialisation et
l'amélioration des process que nous
allons tenter de mettre en place afin de
rendre le dispositif encore plus
efficient et et voilà on nous espérons
vous avoir à nos côtés encore pour
longtemps merci beaucoup merci madame
monsieur Ficot pour la Ligue de football
professionnel
que vous portez à ces sujets je vais
vous demander de bien vouloir m'excuser
si j'enfonce quelques portes ouvertes
mais en avant propos je voudrais
rappeler un certain nombre de choses la
première c'est qu'évidemment le football
et le contenu le plus le plus piraté au
monde et le représente auprès de 75% des
contenus sportifs piratés mais je crois
que cette menace ne doit pas être
circonscrite au seul football
professionnel et on voulait rappeler que
que cette menace qui est
plus imminente puisqu'elle est déjà
passée elle est gigantesque pour
l'industrie du sport mais également pour
tous l'écosystème je ne reviendrai pas
sur la théorie économique du
ruissellement mais ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que tout le monde est
concerné pas que le football
professionnel pas que le football
amateur pas que le sport amateur mais
également un tout tous les acteurs
économiques
sur le territoire
j'ai été aussi très sensible aux propos
de de même bientôt et du président
salada lorsqu'il parle et c'est une
réalité ce n'est pas pour être
politiquement correct ou attirer votre
attention sur les risques encourus par
tous les consommateurs et les
internautes qui sont sur ces sites les
risques encourus de détournement de
données personnelles de de risques
divers et variés lors dépend est une
réalité et ne doit pas être sous-estimée
et enfin et pour moi je à titre
personnel je crois que c'est le plus
grave c'est que l'ensemble de ces sommes
finalement échappe à tout contrôle à
tous mécanismes de solidarité sociétale
à tout un pot et viennent alimenter des
réseaux et aujourd'hui on les appelle
criminels mafieux drogue c'est vraiment
très flou mais très inquiétant et on
sait que toutes ces sommes qui
représentent des milliards d'euros
viennent renforcer des activités
criminelles illégales qui qui est encore
une fois échappe à tout contrôle
je vais faire très vite sur les actions
de la LFP je suis évidemment très très
positif sur les résultats de ce
dispositif ça nous a permis depuis plus
d'un an pour vous donner un ordre d'idée
de bloquer 40000 liens de Live Streaming
tant sur le direct sur les highlights et
près de 300 000 référencements sur
Google ou Bing des moteurs de recherche
extrêmement connus depuis un an
évidemment on a aussi une mission de
surveillance de tous les systèmes d'IPTV
et on sait que sur la saison dernière on
a à peu près 1000 serveurs IPTV i Lego
qui ont été qui ont été identifiés plus
de 4000 chaînes illégales qui sont
monitorées et juste qu'on parle de liptv
et on vous en a beaucoup parlé
aujourd'hui
on a sur un dernier match de de Ligue 1
vu que 300 000 personne était en
connectée un soir de match sur un seul
service IPTV
toutes ces actions là elle n'aurait
évidemment pas été possible sur le
principe de l'ordonnance dynamique
et c'est vrai que je profitais de votre
accueil pour bien sûr remercier la
représentation nationale et le Sénat
mais également vous dire que les
principes de saisine judiciaire de
débats contradictoires d'ordonnance
prononcées par le juge évidemment on les
accepte avec grand plaisir d'autant plus
qu'elles sont dégages nécessaires à un
état de droit mais qu'elle nous semble
représenter au final un dispositif
extrêmement efficace qui nous permet
nous-mêmes diffuseur ayant droit de de
lutter contre contre ce fléau
je vais faire très vite on a parlé des
mesures de blocage DNS un déniablement
et comme le confirme LARCOM dans sa
dernière étude elles ont porté
ses efforts ont porté leurs fruits de
plus en plus d'internautes sont
effectivement confrontés à des mesures
de blocage sur des sitiers légaux mais
comme le président Saada a rappelé on en
perçoit aujourd'hui les limites c'est un
constat je pense que ici ce n'est pas le
forum pour donner quelques publicités à
tous les détails et solutions de
contournement mais c'est une réalité le
blocage DNS est un dispositif qui a fait
ses preuves et qui grâce à
l'automatisation qu'on appelle aussi de
nos vœux et Madame bio je vous en
remercie j'espère qu'on ira très vite
sur ce sujet parce que il continuera à
faire ses à faire ses preuves mais
aujourd'hui sans dispositif de blocage
IP et j'aimerais vraiment réinsister
encore une fois tous les efforts que
nous avons tous fait depuis des années
risquerait de se révéler 20 dans les
prochains mois
sur l'IPTV je vais passer très très
rapidement parce qu'on en a beaucoup
parlé je veux juste rappeler que la
première ligue est une référence à de
nombreux égards pour la Ligue 1 puisque
c'est une ligne référence en terme de de
valeurs et également le Royaume-Uni sur
un certain nombre de dispositifs et que
c'est pour nous une évidence que la
première ligue a fait du blocage IP la
pierre angulaire de son combat puisque
les blocages IP en première ligue
représente 90% des actions y compris
pendant les diffusion du match en direct
donc je veux pas dire qu'on veut copier
les Britanniques d'une façon
systématique mais il faut qu'on prenne
en compte et qu'on en fasse le constat
que c'est une réalité chez eux et que
c'est déjà une réalité chez nous et
aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que c'est
c'est pas pour vous faire plaisir
monsieur rappen mais c'est vrai que je
tiens à louer ici les efforts de l'arcom
et notamment votre ténacité pour qu'un
accord équilibré soit conclu entre la
Fédération française des télécom et
elapse
aujourd'hui pour notre part je ne
pourrai parler de la LFP nous voulons
juste nous comporter de façon
pragmatique on doit être à la hauteur
des enjeux on est évidemment prêt à
contribuer significativement au coût
associé c'était aussi une des raisons au
sein de l'APSE qui a pris un petit peu
de temps pour répondre à la Fédération
française des com c'est que les membres
de laps s'entendent sur une juste
répartition de des coûts donc merci de
votre écoute je voulais juste vous dire
qu'on est dans une courte contre la
montre vraiment je ne parle pas du fait
que la LFP va lancer en 2023 un appel
d'offres qui va être extrêmement
structurant
non pas pour l'économie du football
professionnel mais pour l'économie du
football et du sport dans son ensemble
vous avez tous suivi les derniers
j'allais dire les dernières turbulences
qui ont qui ont touché la Ligue et son
écosystème l'entrée de CVC les ambitions
de la Ligue le besoin effectivement
d'être compétitif au niveau européen
et donc les enjeux se confort
la Ligue comme tout ayant droit doit une
jouissance paisible de ses droits à ses
diffuseurs qu'ils soient Canal+ bein ou
tout nouvel entrant et il y a un réel
questionnement et que je trouve
extrêmement légitime de la part de ces
derniers sur la capacité de l'ayant
droit qu'est la Ligue A garantir cette
jouissance paisible et je ne voudrais
pas nous ne souhaiterions pas que à
l'issue d'un appel d'offres les montants
attendus ou les moments montant
raisonnable ça veut rien dire mais qu'en
tout cas l'optimisation nécessaire de
nos droits ne soient pas en rendez-vous
à cause du risque de piratage et de
normalement l'appréciation des
diffuseurs de dire que le produit va
finalement il vaut moins cher parce que
président Saïda l'a rappelé aujourd'hui
je crois que le plus grand concurrent de
Canal+ va c'est le piratage
donc on se doit d'être à la hauteur de
cet enjeu et j'espère pouvoir compter
sur la coopération en tout cas nous on
sera présent au rendez-vous nos
interlocuteurs pour avoir des modules de
blocage IP et dans des délais notamment
pendant le déroulé des rencontres merci
de votre écoute merci et chacun pour ces
propos liminaires qui est clair bien les
la situation actuelle et puis les
questions
de poursuite que vous avez souligné les
uns les autres sans plus tarder je donne
la parole à notre rapporteur Jean
Raymond Hugonnet pour une première série
de questions
merci monsieur le Président les
occasions de se réjouir ne sont pas
légion donc on va sauter sur celle
d'aujourd'hui que vous nous proposez
avec cette table ronde à savoir répondre
parfaitement aux deux missions que nous
confère l'article 24 de la Constitution
française
l'écriture de la loi et le contrôle a
postériori l'évaluation des politiques
publiques donc j'ai trois questions à
poser avec le recul et m'adressant à aux
membres de cette table ronde avec le
recul est-ce que vous considérez que le
dispositif est suffisamment clair et
qu'il apporte toutes les garanties
juridiques attendues par les différentes
parties je me souviens lors des débats
de
débats homériques c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire notamment sur les voies de
droit en cas de difficulté et donc sur
les modalités de recours est-ce que les
difficultés de cette sorte sont apparues
par ailleurs l'article le fameux article
de la loi du 25 octobre 2021 prévoyait
que le paragraphe 4 du nouvel article
l33-10 du code du sport
le principe d'une répartition du coût
des mesures entre les parties nous avons
bien identifié que la création d'un tel
dispositif de blocage était génératrice
de coûts en particulier pour les FAI et
il est parfaitement légitime que ceux
qui bénéficient de la lutte contre le
piratage concours à la prise en charge
de ce de ce coup c'est ce qui a été un
petit peu évoqué mais je comprends que
les parties n'ont pas été en mesure au
bout d'un an de se mettre d'accord sur
la prise en charge de ce coup
est-ce que cette situation si elle
perdrait pourrait fragiliser la mise en
oeuvre du dispositif faut-il modifier la
loi afin de prévoir par exemple que
l'évaluation de ce coup et sa
répartition entre les parties sont
déterminées par la
et enfin troisième question nous avons
observé que les ayants droits souhaitent
aujourd'hui porter une initiative
législative européenne
quelle serait l'intérêt de cette
démarche pour les éditeurs français
s'ils sont déjà protégés par notre
législation nationale ne craignez-vous
pas que le dispositif qui pourrait être
adopté au niveau européen puisse être
moins protecteur en ouvrant des
échappatoires notamment au gafane qui ne
manqueront pas de se faire entendre à
Bruxelles
merci je vais vous laisser répondre à
ces premières questions avant de passer
la parole à mes collègues qui silence
de
l'article 3 en tant que tel aujourd'hui
l'application est extrêmement simple et
fluide
et je salue d'ailleurs à ce titre
premièrement une justice extrêmement
diligente puisque comme je vous l'ai dit
on obtient des décisions dans un délai
record de deux ou trois jours
deuxièmement je souhaite également
mettre
en avant le comment dire la coopération
des fournisseurs d'accès Internet c'est
à dire qu'il n'y a pas de recours qui a
été qui ont été initiés par aucun
fournisseurs d'accès depuis le lancement
de ces de ces actions judiciaires et
c'est pour ça que nous sommes
extrêmement nous avons dressé un bilan
très positif de l'application de ce
texte puisque voilà nous n'avons pas eu
l'occasion de devoir répondre à ce type
de complexité et je pense que on a tous
un intérêt commun et les failles l'ont
montré lutter efficacement contre le
piratage donc à ce stade je pense que
l'article est suffisamment précis et ne
devrait pas enfin de
nous n'avons pas identifié en tout cas à
ce stade de souhaits de modification de
cet article
peut-être peut-être un mot sur donc la
sécurisation juridique de la mise en
oeuvre du dispositif de piratage à ce
stade
dans la loi il est prévu que s'il y a
une difficulté de la part des
fournisseurs d'accès Internet à pouvoir
mettre en œuvre le blocage qu'on leur
notifie il doit nous en rendre compte et
l'arcome est effectivement habilité à
pouvoir leur demander des explications
sur les difficultés rencontrées à ce
stade en neuf mois nous n'avons eu le
retour d'aucune difficulté et en tout
état de cause si effectivement il y
avait une difficulté il y a toujours la
possibilité pour les ayants droits de
revenir dans le juge donc je crois
effectivement que sur le plan de la
garanties juridiques de mise en oeuvre
efficace du dispositif elles sont
assurées à ce stade
[Musique]
il faut pas négliger quand même que les
ayants droits et les acteurs de la
télévision payante ou gratuite ne sont
pas les seuls à bénéficier de ces
mesures je voudrais quand même rappeler
que les autres opérateurs télécoms
vendre ses services et donc on tire des
marges significatives ne serait-ce que
en ce qui nous concerne le produit
Canal+ de quoi nous distribuions Disney
plus que nos distribuions et ébin que
nous distribuons qui représentent des
montants très importants dans les
revenus et dans les marges les
opérateurs télécoms donc ils ont aussi
eux intérêt à vendre des abonnements
touche des démarches sur ses abonnements
et est-ce que ça se passe bien ça c'est
un élément au bénéfice des opérateurs
télécoms sans compter les opérateurs qui
achètent eux-mêmes des droits sportifs
je rappelle que aujourd'hui Free et
détenteurs d'un lot de Ligue 1 et que
Altis a acheté à investi des sommes
conséquentes et on sait bien parce qu'on
a sous licencié un certain nombre de nos
droits que ce soit sur la première ligue
ou la Ligue des champions qui
diffusaient encore un match hier soir
sur les coûts pour répondre à votre
question
et on est évidemment dans une logique de
partage alors il y a des couches et la
FAI il n'y a pas principalement des
couches et des FAI tout les opérateurs
portent des couilles il y en a beaucoup
chez Canal+ il y en a beaucoup chez lui
il y en a beaucoup à LFP etc mais il est
temps tendu qu'on prendra notre part de
ses coups et moi je n'envise pas compte
tenu de la base des discussions qu'on a
largement initiées maintenant que on y
arrive pas l'envisage pas de difficulté
sur ce sujet là en tout cas sur la
partie déjà identifié la deuxième partie
sur laquelle je sens ma voisine de
droite trépigner qui est l'IPTV où là il
est vrai que nous n'avons pas encore
identifié les limites les coûts et qu'il
faudra qu'on en discute mais sur la
première franchement à ce stade je ne
crois je je ne vois pas de difficulté
résident si vous le permettez il y
aurait-il besoin d'un arbitre à votre
avis dans ce match un peu particulier
[Musique]
le monsieur bonbon office entre les
partistes c'est à dire d'une part les
membres de l'Obs et d'autre part les
membres de la FFT alors j'ajoute pour la
FFT plus free parce que Free n'est pas
membre de la FFT mais est tout à fait
enfin
les abellos pour aller dire mieux que
moi mais tout à fait solidaire en tout
cas des discussions en cours elles sont
extrêmement couragantes j'allais dire
que voilà nous sommes aussi un peu un
aiguillon là
exactement et à ce stade sur la
répartition des coûts en matière
notamment de mise en place d'un système
automatisé de blocage DNS on constate
pas de difficultés et de position
conflictuelle entre entre les acteurs le
sujet reste plus ouvert c'est juste dire
sur les modalités de faisabilité et de
mise en oeuvre de blocages IP et des
coûts
[Musique]
non alors je vais revenir peut-être sur
le partage des coupes puisqu'on nous
sommes aussi directement concernés donc
je me félicite du fait que un accord
soit apporté donc c'est ce qu'on dit
toutes les partenaires autour de la
table donc dans ce cas j'espère qu'on
pourra conclure rapidement parce qu'on
travaille depuis un moment sur le projet
d'accord je regrette par contre qu'on ne
bénéficie pas nous on propose de prendre
en charge la moitié des coûts
d'investissement et la moitié des coûts
opérationnels je ne bénéficie pas à
moitié des dividendes de Canal+ donc
loin de là donc je crois que la
proportionnalité des gains d'une part et
d'autre et pas exactement équivalente
donc je veux bien qu'on fasse une
théorie du ruissellement mais alors là
les elle est très lointaine sur le
blocage IP alors quels sont nos
préoccupations sur le blocage IP d'abord
il y a des exigences juridiques je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure le principe de
proportionnalité est au cœur de la
jurisprudence du Conseil pensionnel est
au cœur de la jurisprudence de la Cour
de justice de l'Union européenne il y a
d'ailleurs une jurisprudence extrêmement
assise qui consacre tant au niveau
concessionnel au niveau du Conseil
d'État au niveau de la Cour de justice
de l'Union européenne que les opérateurs
télécoms la liberté totale de moyens
pour aboutir aux résultats qui est le
blocage
ce sont cependant nous voulons bien
travailler sur les méthodes les plus
innovantes nous n'exclons pas par
principe le blocage JP simplement je
rappelle le cadre juridique pourquoi
est-ce que c'est important parce que
d'abord le blocage JP n'est absolument
pas une garantie par rapport à des
moyens de contournement un blocage JP ça
bloque pas à la source ça bloque un
moyen d'accès et ensuite parce qu'il y a
des exigences techniques et
opérationnelles le blocage IP
présente des risques de surblocage on
l'a vu très récemment en Autriche
lorsqu'il y a eu une saisine directe des
ayants droits des opérateurs télécoms
par les ayants droits
un site internet il a des millions
d'adresses IP ces adresses IP elle reste
pas attachées à un site internet en
particulier ils sont réattribués en
permanence c'est le fonctionnement
d'Internet qui est comme ça c'est pour
ça qu'il y a des risques de surblocage
avec le blocage JP par rapport au
blocage DNS qui est lui est parfaitement
expérimenté maîtrisé solide avec un
blocage IP on n'est pas sûr de pas
bloquer une chaîne de mail de chat même
si c'est seulement pendant 90 minutes
donc ça présente des défis juridiques
parce qu'il y a pas de de mécanisme de
responsabilité afférents et sa présente
aussi
si je sais pas moi WhatsApp nous assigne
parce que pendant 90 minutes le système
de tchat ne fonctionne pas le système de
mail ne fonctionne pas on veut pas que
ce soit nous qui soyons responsables
parce que le blocage IP est pas
parfaitement maîtrisé parce qu'il y a
pas de solution sur étagère on nous
parle d'expérience étrangère nous sommes
prêts à les regarder mais il y a pas du
tout de supériorité avéré par une étude
quelconque du blocage IP sur le blocage
DNS parce que les solutions sont pas
transposables d'un réseau à notre on n'a
pas du tout la même architecture de
réseau qu'en Espagne pas du tout la même
architecture de réseau qu'au Royaume-Uni
il y a pas même pas 4 raisons nationaux
il y a une multiplicité de couches mais
nous sommes d'accord pour étudier nous
sommes d'accord pour discuter un cahier
des charges avec les ayants droits pour
qu'on regarde concrètement comment
pourrait fonctionner le blocage IP et
comment on pourrait éviter ces
mécanismes de surblocage donc on veut
bien travailler un cahier des charges et
on veut bien travailler avec des
principes juridiques clairs sur la
responsabilité si jamais il y a des
surblocages parce que il y aurait une
fourniture d'adresse IP par les ayants
droits ce serait à ce moment-là les
ayants droits qui seraient responsables
et pas nous et j'ai peur que ça ça
déchaîne quand même des
un procès internationaux il y a aussi
potentiellement des effets sur la
qualité de service et la qualité
d'expérience de nos clients nous on a
conçu les réseaux internet pour que ça
circule de manière fluide on n'a pas
conçu les raisons internet pour qu'ils
soient bloqués c'est pas notre principe
de base et enfin bien sûr il faudrait
une compensation qui soit spécifique et
différente de celle qu'on a déjà
mentionné pour l'industrialisation du
processus du blocage DNS merci on a
quand même du mal à comprendre pourquoi
est-ce qu'il fonctionne en Angleterre en
Italie au Portugal et si difficile à
appréhender en France
je vais donner la parole à Madame Gento
pour un intervention rapide et puis
après les sénateurs interviendront
justement on parlait tout à l'heure
d'arbitre ou de tiers qui pourraient
intervenir
s'agissant de notre position nous sommes
des profanes en matière de réseau
télécommunications et je pense que on
discute avec effectivement les
Fédération des télécoms et fruits
sur des choses que l'on ne maîtrise
absolument pas donc si on devait avoir
effectivement l'aide ça serait l'aide
d'un expert en matière de réseau de
technologie de télécommunication
pourquoi parce que comme vous l'avez dit
en Angleterre ça fonctionne très bien en
Italie ça fonctionne très bien le seul
cas de surblocage dont on a connaissance
et un cas en Autriche récemment et c'est
vrai que pour pouvoir même discuter des
coups le partage des coûts on est
d'accord on l'a on le dit on l'a fie on
est prêt à partager les coups si on les
connaît si on sait ce sur quoi il se
base donc c'est là où il faut qu'on ait
une information transparente sur quels
sont comment dire les coûts qui sont
engagés par les failli qu'est-ce qu'ils
font exactement pour le compte des
ayants droits et dans ce cadre là on
discutera du partage des coups et c'est
ce qu'on fait sur le DNS où on a tout à
fait donné notre accord sur ce partage
des coûts même si on pense que le
blocage GNS existait déjà chez la
plupart des FAI et que n'a peut-être pas
nécessité mais en tout cas on a joué le
jeu et on a dit d'accord on y va
s'agissant de l'IP on veut avoir une
discussion en toute transparence et
quand on nous dit nos réseaux français
ne sont pas identiques au réseau anglais
ne sont pas identiques aux réseaux
portugais ne sont pas identiques au
réseau italien on veut simplement avoir
un expert à nos côtés qui puisse nous
dire c'est le cas ou ce n'est pas le cas
je vais donner la parole maintenant mais
collègue Michel Savin Jean-Jacques
Lauzac pierre Toine Lévy Jérémy baquy et
David Assouline Michel
merci président d'abord merci pour cette
présentation alors
il y a deux aspects il y a le premier
l'aspect positif par rapport à ce qui a
été mis en place et les résultats que
vous nous présentez ce matin des
résultats qui sont encourageants sur les
sites et LEGO avec les chiffres que vous
avez présenté
ce qui est encourageant aussi c'est bien
sûr c'est le rôle de l'arcom avec cette
rapidité d'intervention qui permet aussi
d'être Raffort de renforcer ce
dispositif
mais et puis et puis
des discussions pour trouver un accord
sur ce que vous appelez de vos vœux sur
le partage des coups de fonctionnement
pour pour avancer dans le bon
collectivement je trouve que là aussi
c'est un signal positif même si ça prend
un peu de temps on l'a bien compris mais
au moins on sent qu'il y a une volonté
commune d'arriver à trouver une solution
par contre nous avons aussi entendu
qu'il y avait une situation d'urgence
par rapport à ce que vous avez tous
évoqué sur notamment
une nouvelle forme de piratage de
piratage comme vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur Saada ou les des pirates se
sont orientés vers d'autres solutions
notamment les applications et TV des
véganes ou aussi des boîtiers qui sont
aussi en très grand nombre et qui pose
un vrai problème aussi de de sorte de
piratage même pas de sorte de piratage
on se retrouve un peu dans le dans le
même phénomène que le dopage on arrive à
trouver on arrive à trouver le produit
qui est interdit ceux qui sont à
l'origine ont déjà anticipé et ont
trouvé une autre solution pour continuer
le dopage moi j'ai trois questions
monsieur Sada vous avez rappelé que donc
on assiste un report des consommateurs
vers une nouvelle forme du piratage
première question et ça a été un petit
peu avancé déjà avec les Anglais
d'autres pays ont-ils déjà donc
entrepris de mettre en œuvre le blocage
portant sur ce type de blocage et
quel est l'ampleur de l'impact de l'IPTV
illégale en Europe c'est pas un
phénomène uniquement français il serait
intéressant de voir mais vous avez
commencé y répondre vous avez aussi
évoqué les mesures prises dans le
championnat anglais mesdames bilelou
vous avez parlé de prendre les mesures
pour sécuriser le dispositif sur le
risque de surblocage en termes de resp
rentabilité ma question donc les Anglais
ont-ils été confrontés de leur côté
assez difficultés particulières liées
par exemple assez de surblocage bon vous
avez commencé mais c'est vrai qu'il est
difficile pour nous de commencer
possible chez les Anglais ou chez des
voisins espagnols portugais ce qui l'est
pas en France et on se retrouve un peu
dans la discussion que nous avons eu il
y a quelques années au démarrage de ce
travail sur le piratage ou envoyer qui
avait beaucoup de difficultés qu'on est
arrivé avec Catherine brundai arrivé à
faire lever petit à petit et on se
retrouve un petit peu dans la même
situation avec l'IPTV et ma dernière
question vous avez évoqué plusieurs à
évoquer le travail collectif entre
l'ensemble des acteurs comment
envisagez-vous donc la suite notamment
pour la mise en place des blocages IPTV
et dans quel délai parce qu'on voit bien
qu'il y a une urgence aujourd'hui
annoncée par les diffuseurs et pas la
Ligue de football avec aussi le le la
consultation qui va être lancée dans
quelques temps sur le les droits TV sur
de la Ligue de foot il y a un enjeu qui
est même majeur économiquement pour la
Ligue de foot donc il y a quand même une
urgence et dans quels sont les délais à
vos yeux pour trouver des solutions et
apporter des solutions à ce problème
Jean-Jacques flauzac
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président et merci
pour l'organisation de cette de cette
table ronde c'est vrai que on est je
dirais partagé entre d'un côté des
propos très rassurants qui d'ailleurs
avait été tenu également devant nous il
y a quelques semaines par le président
de la recommande concernant
l'application de ce dispositif juridique
nouveau et puis d'autre part des propos
qui restent quand même des propos assez
alarmistes qui sont au moins des propos
de vigilance pour l'application du
dispositif au cours des des mois et des
années des années qui viennent et on a
tous conscience du manque à gagner
considérable que représente le piratage
je dirais pour tous les acteurs que ce
soit l'état les détenteurs des droits et
puis pour l'ensemble de l'écosystème
sportif et encore on n'a pas évoqué un
problème semble-t-il c'est comme
conséquent de ce piratage la
dépréciation de la valeur marchande des
compétitions sportives concernées alors
une première question parce que vous
savez qu'il y a une mission
d'information parlementaire relative au
droit de diffusion audiovisuel
de la protection des droits audiovisuels
avec des moyens humains des moyens
financiers adéquats pour lutter contre
le piratage donc je voudrais savoir si
la LFP de football professionnel dans le
directeur adjoint est parmi nous
pourraient à terme s'emparer encore plus
de cette question et s'investir plus
encore merci
alors avant de passer la parole à Pierre
Antoine et ville juste un mot de
Monsieur raponne puisqu'il doit s'en
aller notamment sur la question
européenne qui avait soulevé genre
à laquelle il n'avait pas été répondu
sur le sur les projets européens on est
à ce stade dans une phase très
exploratoire où la Commission ne veut
pas si je comprends bien entendre parler
de règlement ou de directif c'est-à-dire
d'un cadre contraignant elle est plutôt
sur la voie d'une recommandation
et à ce stade nous avons été mis à
contribution uniquement au sein
d'ailleurs de l'Observatoire de
l'audiovisuel sur la manière dont nous
pratiquions avec les résultats qu'on
vous a donné sans savoir bien si ce
modèle français en quelque sorte un peu
comme on l'a dit innovateur voilà était
de nature à emporter leur conviction ou
pas ou est-ce qu'ils étaient au-delà sur
une recommandation notamment de blocage
à la minute voilà qui est plus
ambitieuse que ce que nous pratiquons
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
oui monsieur président merci pour pour
l'organisation de cette table ronde
alors beaucoup de questions déjà été
posées effectivement on peut solliciter
des résultats déjà enregistrés par grâce
à cette loi de cette loi de 2021 vous
l'avez dit 20% des Français en 2021 ont
regardé des programmes sportifs par le
biais de titre de piranhas de piratage
Michel Savel a précisé il y a des
nouvelles on va dire des nouvelles
astuces et notamment avec les boîtiers
IPTV qui se développent ces dernières
années
lorsqu’un amateur de sport vision d'un
match sur une plateforme pirate il ne
voit pas forcément le mal il sait que
c'est illégal mais il se dit j'imagine
que ce n'est pas bien méchant ça va pas
changer finalement le monde mais
l'addition de ces comportements
individuels pèse très fine au final très
lourdement sur tous l'écosystème
sportifs on estime à pratiquement un
milliard d'euros le manque à gagner ce
qui est ce qui est énorme bien
évidemment sur le plan national
dans le même temps nous savons bien les
difficultés de financement du sport avec
un modèle économique basé principalement
sur les droits de retransmission télé
mais il est aussi important de se poser
la question pourquoi en étant arrivé là
alors soyez royaliste la fraude a
toujours existé
existera toujours de façon résiduelle
lorsque quelque chose est payant
il y aura toujours des astuces pour
contourner le modèle payant cependant il
y a encore 15 ou 20 ans il y avait un
seul diffuseur pour le football
aujourd'hui il y en a plusieurs c'est le
cas en Europe mais au final quand on
regarde le prix payé il est finalement
très très important est-ce que dans le
cadre de votre de cette table là de vos
accords respectifs vous avez la
possibilité également de regarder s'il
est pas possible de rendre plus visible
plus lisible les offres destinées à la
population parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a
plusieurs offres qui existent ça coûte
relativement cher vous avez des efforts
qui sont faits en Europe également il y
a des efforts qui ont été faits on
s'aperçoit que sur poursuivre la Liga la
Champions League pour suivre les
footballeurs européens finalement il
faut débourser beaucoup moins d'argent
qu'en France
est-ce que dans votre
casquette aujourd'hui de régulateur
est-ce que vous avez la possibilité
peut-être d'intervenir pour que ces
offres soient peut-être plus pertinentes
plus lisible pour le je dis pas que ça
va ramener les gens vers des modèles
payants mais en tout cas ça pourrait
peut-être y contribuer merci
Jérémy oui merci monsieur le Président
merci à l'ensemble des intervenants et
des intervenants mes chers collègues
alors moi aussi comme mon collègue
Pierre-Antoine Lévy beaucoup de
questions ont été posées donc je vais
réduire simplement trois questions la
première des questions c'était
savoir si le piratage sportif qui était
en hausse concerné de manière un peu
similaire l'ensemble en tout cas la
progression l'ensemble de des différents
sports même si j'imagine bien que le
football est le sport le plus piraté ça
a été dit à plusieurs reprises mais je
voulais savoir la progression des autres
sports aussi dans le piratage pour
savoir l'ampleur de la situation
deuxième question c'était à ton des
comparatifs sur la nature du piratage à
l'échelle européenne avec d'autres pays
est-ce que la France se place plutôt
parmi les pays qui
piratent le plus et essayer de
comprendre si tel est le cas les raisons
de ce piratage et j'en viens à la
troisième question
fait liens à ce que disait mon collègue
Pierre-Antoine Lévy précédemment
n'y a-t-il pas trop en réalité de
diffuseur et d'opérateurs sportifs en
France on l'a vu avec d'autres
plateformes notamment le cinéma je j'ai
vu l'apparition de Netflix comme
beaucoup avec une offre avec un
catalogue assez impressionnant et une
offre relativement abordable pour
l'ensemble des foyers ce qui a contribué
même si sa règle pas tout bien
évidemment un recul conséquent du
piratage d'un certain nombre de séries
de films voilà donc ma question est
plutôt à Monsieur ficaud dans la
renégociation des droits est-ce que vous
avez par hasard fait une évaluation de
dire est-ce que si on vend les droits à
la fois de la Ligue 1 mais on a un
package complet sur un seul opérateur
finalement ça ferait pas reculer le
piratage et ça permettrait à cette
opérateur d'avoir un profit supérieur à
ce qui pourrait avoir aujourd'hui avec
une multiplication des différents
opérateurs c'est une question peut-être
un peu naïve mais en tout cas je me
permets de je vous remercie
David et souligne
oui merci monsieur le Président
on a
rempli notre rôle de d'évaluer cette loi
et d'avoir le retour des principaux
intéressés aujourd'hui
le débat c'est focalisé sur surtout
est-ce que ça a été efficace oui c'est
innovant oui
est-ce qu'il y a encore des zones de
discussion
IPTV etc oui il y a des améliorations
mais en même temps
on aborde pas
une question qui pour nous législateur
au-delà de favoriser que les opérateurs
privés que vous êtes puissent continuer
à faire leur commerce nous ce qui nous
intéresse
c'est la diffusion du sport c'est les
retours pour le sport de ce que ça peut
générer
et y compris pour l'État en termes de
fiscalité et je suis très étonné qu'on
continue et certains ici ont se
souviennent de ce moment dans les années
2000 on a eu des débats fracassants sur
comment arrêter le piratage de la
musique
et
j'étais parmi ceux qui disaient qu'il
fallait réguler il fallait pas laisser
les choses en pensant que c'est bien
mais en même temps de ceux qui disaient
attention si on n'invente pas un modèle
qui coupe les sources du piratage dire
qui dans une époque où c'était 15 euros
le CD et les momes avaient gratuitement
la musique c'est à dire tant qu'il y
avait pas d'offres commerciales qui
permettait de répondre à cette soif de
culture et de musique de la jeunesse on
avait un problème
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un système
qui est absolument désastreux
pour ceux qui aiment le football et ceux
qui aiment le football n'ont pas
beaucoup d'argent bien sûr que c'est des
très riches qui aiment le football mais
on sait très bien que ce sport est un
sport très populaire
c'est sa nature même et aujourd'hui et
l'entrée dans un stade
pour voir des vrais spectacles avec les
grandes équipes
est absolument inabordable
et voir à la télé
c'est cher
c'est cher parce que si il y a
multiplication et aujourd'hui la Ligue
de football on peut être
comptant au moins qu'il a diffuseur
enfin c'est Amazon
la Ligue de française
donc qu'on fasse semblant
y compris dans une table ronde que ce
sujet n'existe pas
est un vrai problème parce que nous
sommes des législateurs qui travaillent
pour l'intérêt public pas pour l'intérêt
de canal ou de trucs ou de machin même
si je comprends que Canal remplit une
mission d'intérêt public que BeIn Sport
aussi en diffusant du sport le fait que
la Ligue de football est aussi dans
l'intérêt public mais à un moment donné
on doit nous essayer d'évaluer ce qui se
passe et donc aujourd'hui il faut
absolument démocratiser la diffusion du
sport à la télévision
et sur le terrain gratuit et en clair je
vais pas remettre encore sur la table
fait que j'attends un décret là-dessus
bon enfin comme je la jamais rien je
vais continuer à le faire mais surtout
j'aimerais vous poser la question à vous
qui êtes au charbon si vous avez des
réflexions
sur comment faire que le sport ne
devienne pas
l'Opéra
qui a pu être pour les plus pauvres
l'accès à la culture donc voilà je vous
pose la question est-ce que vous avez
ces réflexions et quel est votre
réaction à ce que l'Europe a décidé la
semaine dernière de ne pas aller dans le
sens d'une législation je pense que vous
avez suivi ce que la Commission
européenne a décidé parce que bien
entendu dans ce domaine nous savons que
c'est international et que il faut une
régulation par par l'Europe vous savez
très bien je finis pour revenir à mon
point de départ que la course sera
incessante
sur les nouvelles technologies de
piratage
elle sera incessante donc quand on aura
donc c'est pas tellement le terrain
législatif qui va y répondre c'est
voilà c'est cette course ou à chaque
fois que on a trouvé des techniques de
nouvelles de piratage qui dépasse et
c'est ce qui s'est passé avec la musique
et on a commencé à trouver un équilibre
à l'époque pour la musique
en révolutionnant le mode de financement
on leur révolutionnant et pas on
multipliant les barrières les poursuites
des sanctions et la répression ça ne
veut pas dire que je suis contre au
contraire je suis pour cette loi je suis
pour l'évaluer je suis pour qu'elle je
suis toujours pour l'application de la
loi mais voilà maintenant est-ce que
vous allez commencer à réfléchir à faire
que le sport reste accessible et que ce
soit pas réservé aux plus riches
dernière intervenant
merci Président je crois que tout a été
bien dit il faut bien dit par mes
collègues et lorsqu'on parlait tout à
l'heure de de question naïve moi j'aurai
une question naïve sur l'opportunité de
elle a la possibilité voir l'utilité en
tout cas de mettre en place des
campagnes de prévention télévisées ou en
ligne au sujet dont des piratages de ce
contenu parce que si on peut pas d'un
côté peut-être qu'on pourrait le faire
de l'autre en évoquant les conséquences
du piratage sur les différents acteurs
mais également les sanctions encourues
par les intéressés en tout cas est-ce
que ce sont des arguments qui vous
paraissent insuffisants j'ai bien
compris que les enjeux sont autres ils
sont beaucoup plus importants et c'est
en tout cas une question peut-être trop
naïve merci
merci je vais vous laisser la parole à
plusieurs questions évidemment peut-être
qu'on peut commencer par le premier
sujet qui finalement oriente beaucoup le
reste sur l'organisation de l'offre en
matière sportive et est-ce que pour
rester sur la question du piratage
est-ce que cette offre qui est quand
même très complexe ne génère pas de
manière indirecte du piratage monsieur
salat on a commencé je le serai
un avis sur la question
c'est un peu un paradoxe pour moi parce
que je me suis retrouvé plusieurs fois
devant le conseil d'abord le Conseil de
la concurrence puis l'Autorité de la
concurrence on m'expliquait qu'il
fallait faire rentrer des acteurs donc
pin d'ailleurs et qu'il fallait que
Canal cesse son monopole sur les droits
sportifs etc etc et on a vu avec une
volonté qui était que je comprends qui
était de favoriser la concurrence pour
éviter canal monde trop ses prix c'est
ça et que le consommateur soit pénalisé
et on a vu que la fragmentation de mon
point de vue avait un peu l'effet
contraire avec ce que vous dites et dont
tout le monde subit les conséquences je
et donc je dois faire le constat comme
vous que pour un fan de foot aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué alors il
y a des pays où c'est plus cher mais
mais c'est compliqué et surtout quand on
veut voir la totalité de certaines
compétitions je précise d'ailleurs mais
je veux vraiment pas polémiquer
aujourd'hui là-dessus parce que je suis
venu avec en ami avec Matthieu que nous
avons fait une offre et je réponds
notamment au sénateur à ma gauche qui
est en pleine discussion mais je lui
répond quand même
que nous avons fait une offre pour
l'intégralité des droits de la Ligue 1
qui n'a pas été retenu mais nous avons
bien fait cette offre de la même façon
que nous avons fait une offre pour
l'intégralité la Ligue des champions qui
elle a été retenue et je m'en réjouis
juste pour dire ce que nous donc ce
sujet nous préoccupe je ne dis pas que
nous avons apporté toutes les réponses
mais ce sujet nous préoccupe dans les
réponses que nous y apportons il y a
donc cette volonté de rassembler des
compétitions chez Canal l'intégralité la
deuxième c'est de c'est de quand on fait
de l'agrégation ce qui est un des
métiers de Canal+ et notamment quand on
fait l'agrégation d'une offre sport avec
avec Eurosport avec d'autres offres
sports il y a des avantages tarifaires
je ne dis pas qu'ils sont suffisants
mais il y a des réductions tarifaires et
surtout ce que nous avons engagé il y a
quelques années ce sont des offres
moins coûteuses pour les plus jeunes
aujourd'hui vous le savez toutes les
offres de Canal+ pour les moins de 26
ans sont à moins 50%. voilà donc il y a
une réduction tarifaire sur l'ensemble
des offres y compris de droits sportifs
aujourd'hui canal pour un moins de 26
c'est 12 euros 50 à peu près par mois
sans engagement donc voilà on a changé
toutes nos offres pour que ce soit quand
même plus facile et plus accessible je
laisserai encore une fois Mathieu Figo
revenir sur le sujet de LOF parce que
c'est quand même à la fin lui qui en
récolte les droits je dirais juste que
par rapport à la proposition de mettre
des matchs en clair etc je la comprends
totalement il y a deux choses le je vais
pas polémiquer sur le sujet TF1 mais on
a quand même un petit sujet qui est une
volonté du régulateur et du législateur
que je comprends qui est de dire il faut
qu'un certain nombre de droits
importants majeur soit accessible
gratuitement et de l'autre des chaînes
qui sont ce que vous avez dit
gratuitement clair c'est important qui
viennent nous demander de l'argent qui
viennent nous demander de plus en plus
d'argent même et nous retrouvons dans
une situation où soit on accepte une
augmentation de 50% de ce que nous ce
qui nous a demandé par TF1 soit on est
contraint de ne plus la diffuser et donc
dans ce cas là de mon point de vue c'est
pas canal qui remplit pas son obligation
c'est TF1 qui remplit pas son obligation
de rendre son signal accessible à tous
les Français hein mais il y a un petit
contradiction entre on impose que des
droits soient accessibles gratuitement
sur des chaînes en clair et c'est même
chaînes en clair viennent voir les
opérateurs on leur demande de l'argent
et si c'est pas suffisamment d'argent
ils interrompre le signal parce qu'on
était menacé de contrefaçon par TF1 donc
il y a cette petite contradiction là le
deuxième sujet c'est mais ça c'est un
sujet pour Mathieu et pour la LFP c'est
que mais moi je parle de mon expérience
en termes de droit sportif c'est
qu'évidemment pour faire monter les
droits en général on fait jouer la
concurrence et donc on peut se retrouver
avec une fragmentation et que quand on a
des matchs en clair ça fait généralement
dans tous les marchés observés baisser
la valeur globale de la compétition
c'est voilà c'est une évidence mais là
je parle pour les ombres
[Musique]
consacré au piratage mais je suis ravi
non non mais je suis ravi de de répondre
à toutes les questions même annexes
connexe mais sur le piratage déjà pour
vous dire que
on a bien conscience que
un nouvel entrant
ou une fragmentation de l'offre peut
être un des éléments
d'accélération du phénomène
en aucun cas demain
interdire les nouveaux entrants ou
mettre tous les droits sur un seul
diffuseur le problème du piratage
restera présent et il faudra le traiter
avec les débats les discussions les
outils dont on parle et et
le sénateur insuline disait c'est un une
course incessante c'est vrai qu'on parle
du blocage IP mais peut-être que demain
nous aurons aussi à faire face à
d'autres à d'autres et donc on a ce
devoir de toujours anticiper pour
essayer de protéger la valeur de nos
droits
concernant la diffusion en clair
d'abord la Ligue
et contrainte par le code du sport et
quand j'ai dit contrainte c'est c'est un
jugement pas de valeur de dire on est
malheureux de cet élément là c'est que
la mise sur le marché des droits des
compétitions de la LFP est encadré par
les dispositions du code du sport qui
prévoit
des allotissements un nombre de lots des
procédures un certain nombre de choses
de façon à comme le disait le président
Saada et bien favoriser la lotissement
de plusieurs lois à plusieurs acteurs de
stimuler la concurrence de faire en
sorte que tous les acteurs potentiels
intéressés par les droits de la Ligue 1
quel que soit leur budget quel que soit
leur intérêt puissent mais en tout cas
soumettre des offres et avoir une chance
de récupérer une partie des droits
si demain nous donnions à la possibilité
à la d'ailleurs c'est encadré dans le
temps puisque les droits ne peuvent pas
être mis sur le marché pour une durée
supérieure à 4 ans alors que dans
d'autres territoires notamment aux
États-Unis il est courant d'avoir des
des accords de très longue durée voire
de 10 ans est-ce que pour autant demain
si la Ligue avait la possibilité de
négocier de gré à gré sans passer par un
appel d'offres en négociant avec les uns
ou les autres l'intégralité de ces
droits l'exclusivité de ses droits pour
une période de 10 ans
je sincèrement c'est pas pour être
politiquement correct mais je pense que
ça serait une énorme erreur la Ligue
pour autant et l'assume doit optimiser
la valeur de ses droits
ça fait partie de ces statuts donc on le
fait en essayant de de maximiser nos
revenus et c'est pas un gros mot on le
fait pourquoi on le fait pour offrir le
maximum de compétitivité à nos à nos
clubs sur la scène internationale qui
sont en concurrent avec tous les autres
clubs européens on parlait de la
fiscalité récemment avec des avantages
notamment pour les clubs allemands
puisque souvent et c'est une anecdote on
dit que le Bayern de Munich sur le
séchage social et patronales
finalement montre que tout ce que
la Ligue de l'intégralité de tous les
clubs payent en termes de charges
sociales et patronales en termes de
compétitivité quand vous voulez recruter
des joueurs et ça participe aussi de
l'intérêt des fans au championnats le
fait que Messi Neymar Mbappé ou toutes
les autres stars de Ligue 1 soit dans la
Ligue 1 et bien ça augmente l'intérêt de
tous les fans pour nos compétitions et
ça favorise aussi
[Musique]
pour l'État plus plus d'impôts plus de
contributions sociales et patronales
plus de solidarité sociétale dont je
parlais donc tout ça c'est le le cercle
vertueux auquel on veut arriver donc
pour
terminer sur la question de la diffusion
gratuite ou en clair je je ne crois pas
que la diffusion d'un match par journée
de championnat soit la solution je
prends tout à fait le point que
notamment dans les stades vous avez des
catégories de place à des tarifs
extrêmement différents qui permettent
d'adresser des populations tout à fait
différentes et où les
plus riches d'entre nous peuvent aller
en loge et les plus modestes peuvent
aller regarder un match en catégorie 3
il est vrai que en matière télévisée ou
de retransmission ou d'accès à des
programmes via
un méthode
média c'est tout à fait impossible
pour autant
encore une fois notre rôle de maximiser
les revenus c'est pour rendre nos clubs
les plus compétitifs possibles
je sais pas si j'avais répondu à toutes
vos questions
et l'implication est j'en terminerai de
la Ligue directement contre le piratage
monsieur le Président
sincèrement je crois que le dispositif
est extrêmement efficace je pense encore
une fois qu'il donne tous les gages
notamment
grâce au tribunal judiciaire au juge
judiciaire au débat contradictoire à la
présence de l'arcom comme comme
intermédiaire de tiers de confiance je
pense que nous avons tous les gages et
que nous avons tout de même un
dispositif extrêmement efficace je pense
que l'action dans le temps et notamment
de pouvoir intervenir pendant le déroulé
des rencontres sera un des éléments
déterminants pour rendre notre
dispositif encore plus efficace je ne
crois pas que de donner plus de moyens
qu'il soit rigoaliens ou financier à la
LFP donnerait des résultats plus
efficaces ou différents je pense que le
dispositif aujourd'hui notamment avec
l'apps qui a désignants droits et des
diffuseurs et très efficace il nous
convient parfaitement madame Gento
oui je voulais juste ajouter quelques
éléments s'agissant en premièrement de
l'adaptation de l'offre légale pour
répondre justement à la prolifération
des offres je rappelle juste que BeIn
Sport a été élancé au prix de 11 euros
et rester au prix de 11 euros pendant de
très nombreuses années et qu'aujourd'hui
elle est accessible au prix de 15 euros
je vous rappelle qu'une place de cinéma
au Pathé Gaumont de Beaugrenelle c'est
15 euros donc je mets quand même en
balance pourquoi le sport devrait être
moins cher que le cinéma que répondre
également à la prolifération des
plateformes de cinéma Netflix Disney
plus Universal Amazon enfin voilà le
sport pourquoi le sport vivrait une une
expérience radicalement différente du
cinéma on l'a vu comment dire le sport
coûte extrêmement cher et la gratuité
n'est pas forcément la solution et au
contraire comme l'a dit aussi bien
Mathieu
serait détérioré si le sport ne
disposait pas des moyens financiers
dispose aujourd'hui
voilà ce que je voulais ajouter sur le
sport en gratuit et sur l'adaptation de
l'offre légale madame bellulo
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
rappeler une chose c'est que le Conseil
pensionnel a rendu une décision il y a
quelques jours qui montre que pour que
il y ait des blocages en France c'était
à l'occasion de demande de blocage de
site de vente en ligne frauduleux par la
DGCCRF il faut qu'il y ait soit une
ordonnance du juge soit une injonction
du notoriété administrative qui
remplissent des critères extrêmement
précis donc pour tous les blocages nous
sommes dans la même situation donc c'est
d'ailleurs ce que prévoit l'article
333-10 du code du sport mais ce sera de
toute façon le cadre général il pourra
pas y avoir de saisines directe des
ayants droits pour répondre à vos
questions est-ce que je sais pourquoi ça
fonctionne au Royaume-Uni et ça
fonctionnerait pas en France non je ne
sais pas il y a les seules études qui
sont disponibles c'est une étude de 600
pages du Conseil de l'Europe que j'ai
parcouru dans les détails qui ne dit pas
un mot du blocage IP pour savoir si ce
serait faisable en France pourquoi
est-ce que l'architecture des réseaux
serait comparable ou le pas comparable
il plusieurs plusieurs semaines et
plusieurs mois d'études par des
ingénieurs réseaux pour étudier les
protocoles BGP pour savoir comment ça
fonctionne ce qui est une vérité en deçà
enfin au-delà de la Manche et pas
forcément une vérité en France pour ça
il faut étudier moi je conclus pas avant
même d'avoir étudié on me dit que c'est
efficace moi je veux bien les regarder
je le redis nous sommes tout à fait
d'accord pour faire un cahier des
charges et si j'appelle demain Vodafone
auto free alors dire mais comment vous
fonctionnez sur blocage IP est-ce que je
peux venir étudier vos réseaux pendant
trois semaines je doute qui me diront
bien sûr venaient demain il y a quand
même aussi des des secrets d'affaires
propres à chaque entreprise donc avec
l'aide certainement de l'arcome qui a
aussi un relais avec lofcom au
Royaume-Uni avec l'aide de l'ARCEP qui a
aussi le relais de l'off comme au
Royaume-Uni peut-être que nous pourrions
étudier dans le détail faire une théorie
du bilan moi je conclue pas avant
d'avoir étudié il faut observer est-ce
qu'il y a une supériorité réelle du
blocage IP par rapport au blocage DN par
rapport aux moyennes contournement ça
c'est sûr que non puisque de toute façon
il y a les mêmes enjeux est-ce que par
contre c'est plus efficace en termes de
blocage pourquoi pas ça j'en sais rien
je crois qu'on a compris le désaccord
entre vous sur peut-être avancer
aussi plusieurs sénateurs ont interrogés
je leur réponds faisons les choses dans
l'ordre je comprends que nous avons un
accord à portée de main pour
l'industrialisation du blocage DNS qui a
déjà fait 10 minutes 50% le piratage
faisons les choses dans l'ordre et
pendant ce temps et en parallèle
étudiant le blocage IP je le redis nous
sommes d'accord pour le faire et le
dernier mot pour madame blasel de la
recommande
c'est pas du tout une conclusion c'est
simplement sur le point de l'offre
légale qui a été évoqué parce que c'est
vrai que de notre expérience on sait
bien évidemment que
pour protéger les contenus sur Internet
il faut évidemment conjuguer des moyens
de lutte contre piratage et des moyens
de d'accompagnement de l'offre légale le
développement de l'offre légale
globalement et la partie aux acteurs
privés et nous en tant régulateur en
tout cas tel que le prévoit les textes
on est simplement là je dirais pour
l'accompagner et pour l'encourager on le
fait enfin pardon le sénateur qui
l'évoquait partie mais on a évidemment
des actions de d'éducation de
sensibilisation on la fait par le passé
et on le fera évidemment à nouveau à
l'avenir l'autre élément qu'on peut
apporter c'est éventuellement d'essayer
d'objectiver un peu la façon dont les
regarder le secteur de le développement
des offres enfin pour encore une fois ce
que ce que les textes prévoit et
peut-être cet égard j'aurais rappelé
trois petites choses puisque je me
rappelle autant que le sénateur a
souligne des discussions qu'on avait il
y a 10-15 ans sur le sujet c'est vrai
que le fait que
à l'époque ce qui était beaucoup
reproché aux acteurs c'était l'absence
d'offre légale donc il y a toujours un
c'est toujours un peu amusant de voir
qu'aujourd'hui on peut ou en tout cas on
peut se réjouir que qu'on s'inquiète
aujourd'hui qui est trop d'offre légale
c'est vrai aussi par ailleurs on essaie
souvent de
mettre en avant le modèle qui a été
développé dans le secteur de la musique
et il faut dire que c'est un secteur
dans lequel le piratage drastiquement
baissé dans lequel les consommateurs se
déclarent extrêmement satisfait de
l'offre mais il faut évidemment faire
très attention à la limite des
comparaisons qu'on fait parce que ça
correspond à des secteurs qui sont assez
différents qui reposent sur des
économies très différentes et que non
j'imagine que que vous le savez mais
voilà la solution qui a été trouvée pour
la musique sera pas nécessairement
adaptable pour le dieu visuel c'est ce
qu'on voit bien et ni même pour le sport
en particulier
et enfin un dernier point pardon sur les
équilibres économiques puisque à chaque
fois ça correspond à des usages
différents des consommateurs et c'est
vrai que c'est quand même important de
rappeler c'est particulièrement vrai
dans le sport que les consommateurs qui
ont des pratiques illicitent sont tous
majoritairement la catégorie sociaux
professionnels supérieure et que en tout
cas dans les chiffres qu'on peut
observer c'est pas le fait des
consommateurs les plus dignes
[Musique]
merci merci aux uns et aux autres je
crois que c'est important de faire ce
point un an après l'adoption de la loi
de même que vous avez compris nous
sommes attentifs à la suite satisfait de
de ce premier bilan mais attentif à la
suite des questions se posent et on
regardera avec vigilance votre capacité
à trouver des accords sur les différents
points que vous avez mentionné et si
vous voulez bien on proposera de manière
régulière pas fréquente mais régulière
de refaire le point sur cette question
sur lequel nous sommes très vigilants et
attentifs merci à vous